salue tous en vos grades et qualités qui
sont pour les qualités extrêmement
nombreuses les grades aussi je je
propose que nous démarrions parce qu'un
certain nombre de collègues doivent nous
quitter rapidement et que d'autre part
nous savons euh que cette semaine est
une semaine un peu particulière puisque
beaucoup de collègues sénateurs sont sur
leur territoire parce que il s'y passe
une activité agricole extrêmement
différente de celle prévu en cette
saison qui mobilise beaucoup d'élus donc
je je je vous remercie de votre
compréhension alors je suis très
heureuse que nous nous retrouvions
aujourd'hui le président du Sénat
devrait passer à la fin de notre matinée
qui aura lieu vers 10h30 puisque le le
président et le bureau des Sénat ont
confié à notre délégation d saacration
une mission qui est une sorte de Graal
de de simplification des normes
applicables aux collectivités
territorial je crois qu'aujourd'hui le
compteur dit qu'il y a 400000 normes il
semble qu'il soit un peu bloqué puce que
cela fait un moment qu'on parle des
400000 normes applicables aux
collectivités et en tout cas cette
mission dont Rémy po notre premier
vice-président qui nous rejoint à la
charge consiste à vrer pour rendre les
normes plus
intelligibles pertinente et efficace et
dans la pertinence et l'efficacité il y
a la notion de proportion et de normes
utiles donc notre délégation a souhaité
euh se positionner en tant que force de
proposition et depuis des années de
nombreux travaux euh ont été menés en
son sein en 2016 ces travaux ont
notamment été conduits euh par remémy po
TR sur la simplification de l'urbanisme
et je sais euh chère Madame demain que
vous allez nous faire une impression
extrêmement forte avec le geste que vous
aurez tout à l'heure qui nous aide à
comprendre euh l'exercice auquel nous
nous prêtons et cette PPL sur la
simplification de l'urbanisme qui a été
adoptée ici à l'unanimité n'a pas n'a
pas prospéré le chantier est immense en
matière d'urbanisme beaucoup de
promoteurs nous disent que lorsqu'il
démarre le temps qui s'écoule entre le
moment où il y a une esquise de début de
projet euh et la fin de la construction
le code de l'urbanisme a très souvent
évolué deux ou trois fois ce qui rend
l'exercice extrêmement difficile donc la
simplification des normes reste en tête
des priorités des élus cela a été révélé
lors d'une consultation que nous avons
fait en en 2020 il semble que cette
exaspération cette prise de conscience
que la norme parfois contrevient à
l'action est un peu dans l'air du temps
les agriculteurs en parlent beaucoup les
entreprises aussi donc en 2023 avec donc
notre collègue premier viceprés
président Rémy Poro nous avons pris une
initiative forte en publiant
2023 des solutions structurelles portant
sur la fabrique même de la norme c'est
nous ne sommes pas intéressés au stock
nous avons considéré que à partir de
cette prise de conscience nous pouvions
sans doute réfléchir et nous appliquer
tous à une fabrique de la loi qui soit
plus efficient qui soit plus légère qui
soit moins chargé en inflation normative
et qu'on retrouve ce triple souci
d'utilité de qualité et et d'efficacité
donc nous avons organisé le 16 mars 2023
les états généraux de la simplification
certains de nos invités d'aujourd'hui y
participai ces états généraux de la
simplification ont été clôturés par une
signature un peu particulière entre le
Sénat et le gouvernement d'une charte
d'engagement commun pour la
simplification des normes
applicable aux collectivités
territoriales puisque c'est le champ de
notre délégation donc l'un des
engagements pris par le Sénat dans cette
charte était de sensibiliser les
législateurs que nous sommes parce qu'il
nous arrive ceci ne sera pas répété ni
déformé il arrive que le législateur
contribue parfois
légèrement avec voilà on va dire
légèrement à l'inflation normative mais
en tout cas il nous semblait intéressant
et cela faisait partie des engagements
du Sénat de permettre grâce à vous
madame et Messieurs de nous
sensibiliser aux conséquence de
l'inflation normative sur le pouvoir
d'agir c'est pourquoi au Sénat nous
cultivons plutôt le fait que la loi elle
doit permettre plutôt qu'imposer éormé
en n'oubliant jamais le principe de
Portalis qui est juste on va dire
derrière le président et en face nous
dans l'hémicycle qui rappelle à juste
titre que la loi est faite pour les
hommes et non pas pas les hommes pour la
loi donc la manifestation de ce matin
traduit cet engagement c'est pourquoi
nous avons souhaité ouvrir cette séance
assez assez largement et notre objectif
est de réfléchir aux conséquences
directes et indirectes de l'inflation
normative je rappelle qu'entre 2017 et
2022 les nouvelles normes ont généré un
coût de 2 milliards et demi d'euros de
dépenses supplémentaires pour les
collectivités donc quand nous parlons
d'argent rare de difficulté financement
je pense que nous pourrions aussi sans
doute toiletter les normes ce qui nous
permettrait de diminuer nos dépenses je
salue notre collègue premier
vice-président reméi remémi po avant de
lui laisser la parole donc le 2è acte se
déroulera le 28 mars qui marquera le
premier anniversaire de la Charte donc
nous souhaitons faire un moment un peu
solennel l'idée étant de pratiquer cet
exercice peut-être r en France c'est
celui de l'évaluation et nous proposons
au gouvernement et à nous-mêmes de
présenter une évaluation de de de des
actions correspondant à à nos à nos
engagements donc aujourd'hui nous
abordons le constat si je puis dire et
le 28 mars les solutions donc avant de
conclure je voudrais d'une part préciser
que cette manifestation fait l'objet
d'une captation audiovisuel et d'une
ouverture à la presse d'autre part vous
présenter le déroulé de la manifestation
que nous voulons
très très pédagogique et surtout très
actif donc rémi.3 à qui je vais céder la
parole rappellera les travaux que nous
avons menés expliquera les raisons de
cette inflation normative et les
principales conséquences ensuite je suis
très heureuse d'accueillir ici pour la
première fois Monsieur Gilles carè qui
est le nouveau président du Conseil
national d'évaluation des normes qui
succède à Daniel Lambert et j'ai
l'occasion d'apprécier et de mesurer sa
détermination à être ce hussard de la
norme si si je puis dire merci chergil
carz qui je crois est
extrêmement désireux de travailler avec
nous sur ce qui est un combat collectif
donc David Lisnard le président de la MF
sera présent par une vidéo et il nous
présentera le rôle du comité législatif
et réglementaire que la MF a créé en
2022 et ça sa raison d'être et sans
doute que avec Gilles carè nous parlons
beaucoup des études
d'impact et enfin je suis très heureuse
d'accueillir monsieur wedling qui est
président de la Conférence des
inspecteurs et auditeurs territoriaux je
vous remercie vous nous expliquerez
cette expression que j'aime beaucoup la
cartographie des risques la norme étant
considérée comme un risque et j'aime
beaucoup cette lecture qui inverse le
regard et qui nous amène à avir beaucoup
de de prudence monsieur patri Gérard
avec qui nous avons déjà eu l'occasion
d'entamer un travail très fructueux vous
êtes président adjoint la section de de
de l'administration du Conseil d'État et
vous avez été aussi élu local puisque
vous avez été maire donc nos
préoccupations ne vous sont pas
inconnues et vous nous parlerez des
injonctions paradoxales et de votre
rapport
annuel dont le titre est très sénatorial
si je puis dire parce que il s'appelle
les politiques publiques jusqu'au
dernier qui
et nous nous aimons nous préoccuper de
l'efficacité jusqu'au dernier K et enfin
Madame je parlais de vous et de la forte
impression que vous nous aviez
faite puisque vous êtes rédactrice en
chef de Dallos d'actualité juridique et
vous nous présenterez le point de vue
des juristes des collectivités sur
l'inflation des Nmes et le président
devrait nous rejoindre à 10h30 merci à
tous cher Monsieur le vice Président je
vous passe la parole bien merci merci
madame la Présidente euh donc Mesdames
Messieurs les les présidents euh et mes
mes chers
collègues la
présidente vient de le dire la la
simplification effectivement des normes
applicables aux collectivités et bien
figure parmi les les vraiment les
priorités de des élus he c'est les plus
fortes priorités quand on les interroge
et ces derniers regrettent que les
les tentatives qui ont été opérées
jusque là malheureusement pour à la fois
maîtriser les les flux et puis parfois
travailler sur le le stock n'est pas
produit les les résultats la hauteur de
des enjeux et moi je vois bien sur le
terrain quand on a no nos associations
des de Mair et qu'on fait nos assemblées
général et quand je leur parle de de
simplification et il il nous sourit un
petit peu au nez parce que ils ont
plutôt l'impression que plus on
simplifie plus on complexifie
malheureusement donc on ajoute parfois
de la complexité en voulant simplifier
et le défi du découragement des élus
s'ajoute bien sûr à la difficulté de la
tâche et leur confiance en nous est
primordial et nous oblige alors c'est
pourquoi il y a il y a voilà un an
bientôt on a signé avec Madame Gattel
notre présidente un rapport au titre
volontairement provocateur puisque
on l'avait baptisé face à l'addiction
aux normes osons une thérapie de choc et
on n pas voulu aller plus loin et
retenir une formule que beaucoup employé
et en employant le le mot de harcèlement
textuel donc on sait pas on n pas osé de
mettre ce titre pour un certain nombre
de raisons vous le comprendrez une
expression que beaucoup d'élus utilisai
alors
finalement comment casser cette machine
infernale de production de de norm voyez
qu'on est il y a pas que les
agriculteurs qui ont des normes ils en
ont beaucoup mais nous également dans
nos collectivités et nous proposons des
pistes pour améliorer donc le processus
de fabrique de normes qui est imposé aux
collectivités
territoriales d'abord il est essentiel
d'agir sur la de manière préventive
plutôt que s'épuiser à simplifier à
postériori des normes qui sont déjà
produites c'est encore beaucoup plus
compliqué d' on a
parfois évoquer de dire quand on amène
une norme on en supprime deux bon ça se
fait
enangleterre mais on a on a du mal chez
nous à à à le recommander et puis donc
ce
rapport porte sur six recommandations
pour corriger les défauts qui affectent
les mécanismes de production
des lois des décrets il privilégie des
solutions plutôt simples qui peuvent
être mises en œuvre pour l'essentiel à
droit constant c'est-à-dire par simple
engagement des acteurs alors c'est bien
de s'engager après il faut que ça soit
efficace alors on y reviendra le 28 mars
puisque on aura notre rencontre sur ce
point là mais chacun d'entre nous doit
d'or et déjà être sensibilité aux
conséquences de ce que nous votons en
terme de complexité du droit applicable
aux collectivité et c'est un peu la
raison pour laquelle moi j'avais proposé
à un moment donné que dans la délégation
on est un référent ou deux dans chaque
commission pour être un peu le la veille
sur les les textes qui défilaient dans
chaque commission pour l'instant on n
pas réussi
à imposer ça à notre au bureau et à nos
présidents de commission de craindre
parfois qu'on soit en ingérence dans
leur commission mais c'est pas le le but
c'était surtout de de d'être en veille
parce que on s'aperçoit qu'à chaque fois
il y a des des amendements il y a
toujours une norme qui se cache
derrière donc c'est ces conséquences je
disais sont importantes l'inflation
normative complexifie bien sûr les
projets locaux en retard la réalisation
on augmente également le coût
euh parfois de façon disproportionnée et
notamment pour les petites communes qui
ont finalement euh d'abord des
ressources humaines et et financières
moindres mais qui ont finalement les
mêmes normes que vous soyez dans une
commune de 200 habitants ou une ville de
100000 habitants les normes sont les
mêmes pour les salles polilyvalent pour
les accès au au gymnases et cetera quoi
que dans les petites communes on a pas
de gymnase mais c'est pas la bonne
référence mais bon il faudrait qu'on ait
des des normes qui soient propor nel
aussi au nombre d'habitants et puis la
multiplication des Nmes constitue
adéiablement un frein au au
développement des territoire dans un
contexte budgétaire que tout le monde
sait contraint et il est donc difficile
d'objectivier la situation à l'heure
actuelle on n pas de thermomètre
finalement qui nous permet de mesurer la
ce qu'on appelle la fiève normative et
son évolution dans le temps on dit
toujours ça fait ça fait 10 ans ou 15
ans que j'entends dire on a 400000
normes mais j'ai l'impression que
aujourd'hui on doit être à beaucoup plus
euh mais ça repose tout ces 400000 Nmes
sur aucun recensement qui a été fait
rigoureusement peut-être que monsieur le
Président de la cnen a l'occasion de se
pencher sur ce le nombre de normes mais
je pense que il doit être beaucoup plus
important euh toutefois cette inflation
normative a des répercussions
financières évidemment directes et
indirectes sur la conduite des grandes
politiques publiques locales et on a une
consultation qui av été menée par le
Sénat en janvier 2023 et qui avait
démontré que quatre élus sur 5 déplorent
les conséquences financières négative du
poids des normes
euh ça se traduit par une augmentation
directe des coûts de la collectivité
pour 30 % des des élus répondants selon
le rapport d'activité du cnen les normes
réglementaire représente en 2022 un coût
net de 2,5 milliards
d'euros pour les collectivités alors je
pense que ça va être
actualisé très prochainement pour
l'année 2023 ensuite on a une
augmentation aussi indirecte des coûts
pour 70 % des répondants
euh avec des modifications des reports
ou des abandons de projets locaux on a
souvent ça on dépose un un dossier à la
de TER et puis quand on s'aperçoit qu'on
fait l'appel d'ofre il y a des surcoups
ben on abandonne le projet parce que ça
ça coûte plus cher que que prévu ensuite
les élus nous mettent en garde euh en
disant plus les normes sont nombreuses
et plus elles risquent de générer des
contradictions pour les élus c'estàd que
sur ce qu'on appelle les injonctions
paradoxales et parfois les injonctions
aussi euh enfin contradictoire he qu
dont on parle de souvent et puis plus
elles sont complexes plus elles risquent
d'être interprété différemment alors
selon les les services déconcentrés mais
aussi parfois en fonction des
départements d'un département à l'autre
on n' jamais la même lecture des décrets
et ça ça pose un vrai problème pour nos
élus euh et puis
alors les élus se se posent la question
quelles sont les causes de cette
prolifération en comp et
complexification des normes alors il y
en a plusieurs euh on me dit trois mais
je pense qu'il y a il y a plus de plus
de trois raisons pour le fait qu' qu'on
ait beaucoup de de normes d'abord en
premier lieu notre droit intègre
beaucoup de politiques publiques donc
chacune poursuit des objectifs aussi
légitime que potentiellement
divergent évidemment je pense aux
objectifs environnementaux qui sont
souvent la euh la folie normative que
rencontent les agriculteurs et qui
nécessairement crée de la norme en
deuxième lieu on nous poursuivons un
objectif de précision normative
c'està-dire qu'on veut toujours aller au
plus
près c'est c'est en allant justement au
plus près qu'on qu'on génère de la norme
pour répondre à la judiciarisation de
notre société parce qu'on on a
l'impression qu'en disant plus la norme
vaêtre être précise moi on aura de
problème juridique ce qui est pas
forcément la réalité en effet les décis
de la norme réclament des normes
toujours plus détaillé pour se prémunir
d'une mise en jeu de de la
responsabilité alors qu'il faudrait
peut-être m avoir un droit souple qui
soit plus facile à
gérer enfin l'emballement normatif tient
sans doute aussi une croyance
quasimistique dans la capacité de la
norme à améliorer l'intérêt général et
ça c'est un très très français hein
quand on sait pas répondre à une
question qu'on manque de moyens
financiers on a souvent l'impression que
les pouvoirs
publics cent volontiers à la création de
la norme magique pour essayer de se dire
bon finalement comme ça on sera
tranquille on dépensera moins d'argent
puisque ça va tellement être complexe et
ça c'est un peu ça donne l'impression
mais c'est plus c'est un peu la
réalité et ils ont l'impression
finalement avec cette norme d'avoir
réglé le problème bon c'est pas toujours
le cas et puis euh forceer d'admettre
également que nous parlementaires on a
aussi une grande
responsabilité d'abord on il faut dire
qu'en France on est le pays où on vote
le plus de lois on vote entre 45 et 50
textes de loi par an alors que nos
collègues voisins européens sont plutôt
en entre 15 et 17
pour l'Allemagne une vingtaine pour
l'Angleterre enfin en fonction des des
années donc déjà si on à partir du
moment on vote le double ou ou le triple
de lois on a forcément derrière des des
normes qui qui tombent ça qui enfin qui
tombent pas c'est qui nous sont imposé
donc plus on légifère mais après nous
quand on on regarde le nombre
d'amendements que nous déposons sur un
certain nombre de textes euh on a cette
part de responsabilité
euh on a plus de
46000 amendements déposés en séance au
Sénat lors de la dernière législature
2017-2022 et plus de 200000 amendements
à l'Assemblée nationale je pourrais vous
montrer enfin si vous voulez le les
chiffres c'est assez
impressionnant donc je forme le le veut
de cette matinée que qu'elle permette
une prise de conscience collective des
conséquences de l'inflation normative
sur le pouvoir d'agir des collectivités
mais je suis bien sûr convaincu que seul
une forte volonté politique commune une
autodiscipline de de nos collègues et
bien permettront un profond changement
de de culture et de pratique euh donc
voilà merci en tout cas de votre
attention
et j'espère que cette patinée sera bien
sûr
fructueuse merci cher Rémi Po et merci
pour ta détermination à conduire cette
mission de la chasse aux normes inutiles
et coûteuse donc Rémy pore l'a dit c'est
vraiment un combat une détermination qui
doit être collective ce que plusieurs
acteurs contribuent à la norme qui qui a
enflé aussi en raison même de
l'évolution de la société reméi poter
l'a dit et de la
judiciarisation qui fait que même les
élus locaux qui ne sont pas totalement
addictes aux normes demandent parfois
l'édction de norme pour être protégé et
sécurisé on a eu l'occasion d'en parler
hier avec une collègue à propos de
l'éclairage public qui a je rappelle
après la crise de l'augmentation des
coûts de l'énergie diminué dans toutes
les communes il y a trois maires qui
avaient écrit à l'époque à la ministre
pour demander que la norme du temps
d'éclairage soit définie par la loi ou
par un décret pour alléger euh ces ces
Maes de tout risque de responsabilité
donc cher Gill un acteur important
euh euh puisque vous êtes le président
du Conseil national d'évaluation des
normes et vous avez une longue
expérience d'élu euh local et nationale
et je suis très heureuse que vous ayez
consenti à prendre la succession d'Alain
Lambert qui étit euh pour nous un
partenaire remarquable et qui était euh
vraiment euh quelqu'un enfin un un vrai
soldat de de la norme alors j'ai aimé
euh l'expression qui figure ou que j'ai
entendu au Conseil national d'évaluation
des normes normes débridé élu empêché ça
ressemble une sorte de slogan de
manifestation nous n'en sommes pas là
mais je crois que ce sont quelques mots
très simples euh mais qui expliquent
bien les choses alors je vous propose
monsieur le Président de vous laisser la
parole avant que nous puissions ensuite
entendre David lissnard président de
l'association des Maes monsieur le
Président bien merci madame la
Présidente merci monsieur le Président
euh je suis très heureux de votre
invitation j'ai toujours plaisir à me
retrouver au au Sénat où j'ai participé
à des si ce n'est des centaines de
commissions mixtes paritaires notamment
sur les lois de finances et je voudrais
enfin tout d'abord bon rendre hommage au
travail d'Alain Lambert dans cette
maison parce que si on a aujourd'hui un
conseil national d'évaluation des norme
qui est reconnue dans le paysage c'est
grâce au travail d'Alain Lambert je
rappelle que
euh à l'origine le conseil c'est une
simple commission que nous avions créé
en 2009 au sein du Comité des finances
locales que je présidais à l'époque et
Alain Lambert avait accepté d'en prendre
la responsabilité je fais ce rappel
parce que la première
préoccupation liée aux normes c'était
d'abord une préoccupation financière
essayer de voir combien ça coûte quel
est l'impact sur les finances local et
puis
euh
rapidement bon le sujet s'est imposé
dans d'autres dimensions notamment les
dimensions qu'évoquait le président
pointerau de de souci de
simplification complexité technique
administrative au-delà même des
conséquences financières et en 2013 il a
été décidé de donner enfin une autonomie
complète à cette structure et par une
loi de l'automne 2013 elle a été
transformée en conseil national
d'évaluation des normes qui se compose
je pense qu'on peut passer le slide
suivant donc de 36 membres avec bon une
majorité des 2/ers d'élus un peu à
l'image d'ailleurs de la composition du
comité des finances locales il y a 27
élus dont quatre parlementaires deux
sénateurs dont bon vous cher Françoise
je sais pas si le second euh doit être
désigné prochainement euh
par rouvellement oui oui parce qu'il y a
le renouvellement et puis deux députés
avec bon notamment Véronique louvagie
qui est tout à fait active il y a quatre
présidents représentants des conseils
départementaux quatre présidents
représentant des conseils régionaux et
puis 15 maires ou présidents
d'intercommunalité pour représenter le
le bloc communal et puis neuf
représentants de de l'État donc la
compétence de ce
conseil est
euh cisine est obligatoire sur tout ce
qui concerne les projet de loi les
projets de loi je dis bien pas les
propositions de loi mais les projets de
loi et au plan réglementaire l'ensemble
des euh décrets et arrêtés enfin des
textes qui comportent de la norme nous
ne n'intervenons pas sur ce qu'on
appelle le droit souple les circulaires
ou ou les guides de bonnes pratique et
le travail s'effectue de la façon
suivante
euh le texte en amont doit faire l'objet
d'une concertation et nous sommes très
vigilants sur ce point d'une
concertation avec les associations
d'élus locaux les maires la MF la RF les
régions la DF notamment
et nous commençons par vérifier que
cette con conertation a bien eu lieu en
amont y compris donc je le dis pour les
textes les textes de loi et le texte est
présenté devant le conseil alors s'il
s'agit d'un texte de loi évidemment le
Conseil n'a qu'une capacité
d'intervention réduite parce que il y a
la légitimité du Parlement qu' est hors
de question de remettre en cause mais je
diraiis un mot dans un instant sur les
textes de loi
et nous pouvons cela étant émettre un
avis bon théoriquement défavorable sur
un projet de loi ce que nous ne faisons
pas n nous émettrons des réserves nous
ne pouvons pas prononcer le report parce
qu'il y a le temps législatif donc les
moyens du conseil sont beaucoup plus
limités mais il n'en demeure pas moins
que son avis qui relaye notamment les
positions des élus locaux peut être
précieux et être intégré parce que cet
avis intervient en amont c'est cela son
intérêt il intervient avant même que le
Conseil d'État soit saisi du texte et
donc l'avis va figurer dans bon l'examen
auquel procédera le le Conseil d'État et
j'ai eu l'occasion de
rencontrer Monsieur tabuto et puis
madame de boid tout récemment qui bon
m'ont indiqué tous les deux qu'ils
attachaient vraiment ils attachaient de
l'importance et par sous le contrôle de
mon ami Patrick gerérard qu'ils attacha
de l'importance bon à ce type
d'avis le travail se concentre peut-être
surtout sur les textes réglementaires
les projets de de décret et là nous
avons le même procédure concertation en
amont on vérifie que cette concertation
a eu lieu et au vu de l'examen du texte
nous pouvons émettre euh soit une
décision de report et là c'est le
président qui la tient parce que si le
texte ne nous satisfait pas pose
problème on peut se donner un délai pour
y retravailler et euh il y a la
possibilité de donner évidemment un avis
favorable si euh bon euh tout s'est bien
passé ou euh un avis euh en général
après une décision de report où le texte
n'a pas été modifié un avis défavorable
et en cas d'avis défavorable le texte
doit obligatoirement repasser
devant le conseil et dans cette
situation le gouvernement doit soit
avoir modifié son texte soit présenter
de façon approfondie les raisons pour
lesquelles il ne peut pas le faire donc
vous voyez quand même une certaine
contrainte et là moi je ne préside enfin
je ne siège au cnen que véritablement
depuis le début décembre et ça fait déjà
deux ou trois textes sur lequel nous
avons prononcé un report une menace
d'avis défavorable et le texte nous
revient en ayant obtenu satisfaction sur
un certain nombre de euh de proposition
le point important on va passer
au au slide
suivant ce sont la qualité des études
d'impact on ninistera jamais assez sur
la qualité des études d'impact et
l'étude d'impact elle est d'Oren avant
obligatoire depuis la réforme
constitutionnelle de 2000 8 sur les
projets de
loi et même s'il y a pas de de fondement
constitutionnel en fonction de
circulaires qui se sont succédés depuis
au moins une quinzaine d'années les deux
faites obligatoires on appelle ça une
évaluation préalable étude d'impact sur
les textes réglementaires et l'étude
d'impact doit commencer
par examiner la situation du droit moi
j'insiste beaucoup sur ce point la
première question a-t-on besoin de
légiférer a-t-on besoin de réglementer
est-ce que le droit existant est euh
totalement utilisé et appliqué c'est la
première question or euh il faut
reconnaître que beaucoup d'études
d'impact en fait sont des justifications
à postériori
euh alors que cette question
fondamentale n'est pas sincèrement
examiné ensuite il faut qu'on Procé à
l'analyse des charges supplémentaires
alors ces charges sont impressionnantes
mais si je prends l'exemple des 2,5
milliards de
2022 qui sont tirés de l'analyse des
études d'impact sur tous les textes
réglementaire 1,7 milliards provient
exclusivement des décrets qui ont mis en
œuvre la régulation thermique dans les
bâtiments publics donc il y a un coût
très important la euh les premières
années on peut espérer après que ça se
traduit par par des économies euh en
2000 c'était en en
2019 on avait 1,5 milliard de coupts
puisque chaque année dans le cadre d'un
rapport le président po me poser la
question le rapport sur 2023 va sortir
dans 15 jours donc j'ai pas encore les
chiffres consolidés mais en 2019 on
était à 1,5 milliard de coups en 2020 à
1,3 milliard de coupts mais si prends
l'exemple de 2020 les coûts
supplémentaires étaient notamment à la
charge des départements liés à la
prestation à l'amélioration de la
prestation de compensation du handicap
donc vous avez des mesures de toutes
sortes vous avez les mesures aussi liées
au au à fonction publique aux mesures
catégorielle par exemple la prime qui
vient d'être décidée la prime
exceptionnelle pour les revenus enfin
les traitements modestes enfin dans dans
la fonction publique en général euh donc
on a des origines de coût de toutes
sortes mais euh aujourd'hui nous avons
un foyer qui est particulièrement
virulent et qu'il faut surveiller de
très près c'est le foyer lié à la
transition euh écologique c'est là
vraiment que alors c'est un double foyer
parce que c'est des coûtes mais c'est
aussi c'est une complexité infinie et
c'est là qu'il faut vraiment se poser la
question de la proportionnalité euh de
la mesure est-ce que ces mesures est-ce
que l'objectif recherché nécessite la
mise en place autant d'autant de moyens
ou de complexité euh bon par rapport au
résultats qu'on est susceptible
d'obtenir donc j'insiste beaucoup sur
les études d'impact et puis pour
terminer parce que je veux pas être trop
long je voudrais dire que en matière de
norme nous sommes tous responsables et
si on veut ça vous vous l'avez très bien
dit il y a un instant si on veut
vraiment simplifier étant entendu au
passage que s'agissant du
CN on est victime d'un tel flux il y a
pratiquement un texte par jour ENF 270
textes en 2023 plus de 300 en 2021 donc
c'est très difficile en 2022 donc c'est
très difficile de
euh d'analyser le stock moi j'espère
qu'on va arriver à à prendre un peu de
temps pour faire un travail en
identifiant très bien un secteur précis
je pense par exemple au secteur
urbanisme logement où bon beaucoup de
normes conduisent à la paralysie mais là
le décortiquer aller jusqu'au bout du
bout pour essayer de de de voir comment
on s'y prend mais et je termine par ça
nous sommes tous responsables tous
responsables j'ai été longtemps
parlementaire mais j'ai vu l'évolution
des textes d'abord gouvernement euh bon
en l'espace de de 30 années où j'ai
siégé à l'assemblée moi j'ai vu les
textes rallonger des textes à tiroir
devenir de plus en plus longs les
amendements mais c'est terrible c'est
terrifiant les amendements chez nous
d'ailleurs il y a un logiciel qui permet
de fabriquer automatiquement les
amendements là et loi par exemple sur la
première partie de la loi de finances
j'étis pendant les 15 années où je
suivais ça de très près soit comme
rapporteur général soit comme président
de la Commission on avait en première
partie sur la loi de finances annuelle
disons tr
300 amendements à la commission des
finances et puis 500 maximum en séance
aujourd'hui c'est 10000 aujourd'hui
c'est 10000 comment voulez-vous
travailler dans ces conditions et
surtout de façon très très sincère nous
voulons tout prévoir dans la loi et ça
je vous l'avais très bien dit Monsieur
pore
c'est c'est c'est un peu une maladie
française on on on veut tout prévoir
comme si il y avait d'abord une sorte de
défiance par rapport aux acteurs et puis
tout prévoir pour précisément avoir une
réponse juridique à tout mais ça conduit
en fait et j' le vois bien au cnen à
avoir sur la base de lois déjà complexe
au niveau gouvernemental qui double de
volume après leur passage au Parlement
on a des textes d'application sur
lesquels on a aucune marge de manœuvre
donc nous nous donnons un avis
défavorable mais en fait bon c'est la
loi qui qui aurait dû bon être être plus
simple il y a un exemple qui me vient en
tête parce que les les les mots sont
même am enfin amusants si on peut dire
la loi climat résilience on a vu
récemment un
décret d'application sur la bonne
manière aujourd'hui de faire des parcs
de stationnement ouverts alors des parcs
de stationnement ils doivent maintenant
comporter absolument des dispositifs
permettant d'éviter les alus de chaleur
de récupérer la chaleur donc dans la loi
on parle des ZES ombrière et on décrit
avec un luxe de détail la manière dont
une ombrière doit fonctionner il faut
qu'elle utilise de l'énergie
renouvelable et cetera et cetera même
chose pour les circuits d'évacuation
d'eau ça c'est la loi arrive le décret
d'application euh on parle d'omrière
mais on parle même maintenant de canopé
et donc on définit dans le décret la
canopée les caractéristiques des
feuillages des arbres qui doivent être
obligatoirement plantés selon le nombre
de places de stationnement bon c'est
complètement c'est c'est c'est c'est
absurde c'est absurde en voyant ça je me
disais on a fait récemment un beau
parking ben ben comme en imitant
d'ailleurs celui de la mairie de Vincen
euh guide de bonnees pratique où c'est
la Vincen qui nous a imité mais jamais
on aurait pu faire ce par ce parc de
stationnement avec de telles contraintes
et donc on a un problème de de vraiment
de de enfin de confiance enfin laisser
les acteurs mais mais la norme c'est
ambivalent c'està-dire que vous l'avez
très bien dit tous les deux tout à
l'heure elle remonte aussi du terrain on
l'a vu pendant la crise sanitaire les
parents d'élèves les épades les maires
euxmêmes qui demandent l'cl vous citiez
Françoise
l'éclairage bon et donc et là je me
tourne vers mon voisin qui va intervenir
sur le problème de risque si on veut
alléger
simplifier il faut qu'on accepte une
certaine prise de risque mais cette de
risque elle ne doit pas non plus
déboucher
sur sur des risques démesurés notamment
au au pénal et là je me tourne vers mon
voisin de droite je me souviens de la
situation terrible parce que j'ai fait
beaucoup quand j'étais auprès de de
Jean-Paul delevoie président de la
mfoccuper des finances j'ai animé
beaucoup d'associations de d'assemblée
générale de de Mair dans les
départements et je me souviens de cas
qui remonta mais mais c'était absolument
effrayant et heureusement il y a eu
cette loi Fauchon de mémoire dans cette
maison qui a permis sinon c'était
impossible de prendre le le moindre
risque donc il y a une corrélation entre
le degré de risque que l'on veut prendre
et puis la manière dont on peut en dont
on peut simpimplifier et puis un dernier
mot pour que ça marche il nous faut un
état déconcentré un état déconcentré
avec des préfets de département qui sont
les vrais patrons qui soient les patrons
de toutes les administrations et des
agences et que ces préfets puissent
déroger puisse adapter puisse déroger et
puisse finalement prendre des risques
dans un dialogue avec les exécutifs
locaux voilà quelques éléments d'analyse
à ce stade en tout cas merci de votre
invitation et puis on va essayer de
faire au mieux parce que le paradoxe
c'est on est schizophrène on est tous
d'accord tous d'accord et puis on
assiste sur le terrain on a l'impression
que c'est le contraire qui se passe
malgré notre bonne
volonté voilà merci merci beaucoup
monsieur le Président je propose qu'on a
un petit échange de deux ou trois
questions avec le président caret juste
de choses dans le rapport que nous avons
fait les préconisations avec notre
collègue Remy Poro nous avons proposé
qu'il yit avant tout dépôt d'un projet
de loi une étude d'option c'est-à-dire
que l'État prouve la
nécessité de disposition législativ
supplémentairire parce que je pense que
c'est un vrai sujet et le deuxème point
cher Gil mais vous êtes à la délégation
chez vous parce que nous avons un esprit
un peu commun parce que vous venez de
parler des services déconcentrés de
l'État nos collègues Éric kerouge agès
caniller ont produit un mode d'emploi
qui est tout à fait disponible
immédiatement et très
opérationnel pour que l'État s'en
inspire parce que je je pense
qu'effectivement il y a des réalités
locales qui font que la norme doit être
adaptée à des
situation de de de taille de commune de
localisation et ceera enfin la norme
elle doit aussi être intelligente et on
doit laisser au préfet la capacité
adapter les choses tout en
sécurisant le le process pour éviter
merci beaucoup donc chers collègues je
vous en prie euh madame Jorda si vous
permettez chers collègues monsieur
chevalier merci madame le
Président bonjour bonjour bonjour à tous
merci de ce diagnosticque qui je crois
est totalement partagé par tout le monde
et depuis longtemps et c'est ça qui
finalement le rend un peu inquiétant je
crois qu'on a complètement perdu de vue
ce quiétait le droit le droit n'est
qu'un outil au service de de nos projets
de nos politiques hein c'est un outil
purement et simplement encore faut-il
avoir des politiques claires et on a
vraiment le sentiment que le droit
devient détourn de son son objet
aujourd'hui d'abord parce que je pense
que chacun s'en sert à son profil les
gouvernements veulent montrer qu'ils ne
sont pas impuissants les parlementaires
veulent montrer qu'ils travaillent et
tout le monde produit autant qu'il peut
autant qu'il peut le texte et puis je
crois qu'effectivement on a un amour de
la norme EN FRANCE qui est hors du
commun moi j'ai coutume de dire qu' en
France un espace de liberté on appelle
ça un vide juridique dès qu'on a' pas de
droit on on on on est malade et et euh
jusqu'au syndrome de Stockholm puisqu'on
on finit j'ai vu certains entrepreneurs
qui disaient mais nous on veut pas se
lancer là-dedans parce qu'il y a pas de
texte bah justement c'est la liberté
allez-y et ils ont peur toujours
effectivement d'être rattrapés par la la
patrouille législative ou ou judiciaire
et on se rend compte que finalement
c'est une nouvelle culture qu'il
faudrait insuffler puisque nous avons
tous fait le diagnostic ici nous sommes
effectivement dans une forme de
dédoublement de la personnalité puisque
tout le monde à peu près les sénateurs
ont tous à peu près piloté un exécutif
que ce soit une mairie un conseil
départemental nous savons à quel point
ça nous est pénible mais ça n'est quand
même pas notre jumeau maléfique qui
dépose des amendements à notre place
quoi donc on on on contribue très
largement à cette à cette inflation et
il il me semble que c'est cette culture
qui nous manque alors qui passe par par
des choses extrêmement claires vous avez
parlé des études d'impact mais je crois
que le Conseil constitutionnel lui-même
avait affaibli la portée des études
d'impact en disant que finalement en
validant des études qui étaient un peu
vided de sens les gouvernements ont
coutume de faire déposer par leurs
parlementaires des des des propositions
loi qui elles sont dispensé d'études
d'impact et puis et j'associe mon
collègue Cédric Vial juste devant moi à
ça car nous venons d'échanger ce propos
sur lequel nous sommes d'accords
nous étudions les impacts nous
n'étudions jamais la réalité des impacts
c'est-à-dire une fois que nous avons
voté il faut faire une évaluation aussi
des textes et je trouve que l'évaluation
qui est quand même un peu le rôle du
Parlement plutôt que de la faire dans la
réalité nous la faisons dans le cadre de
débat qui finalement n'apporte pas
grand-chose à la réalité de l'évaluation
donc ma question est vraiment comment
peut-on insuffler une véritable culture
de de de d'énormis je ne sais pas
comment on pourra appeler ça une culture
qui nous rappelle que le droit n'est
qu'un outil et que cet outil ne doit pas
entrer dans les détails de la vie de
chacun la règle est générale et ensuite
c'est sur le terrain qu'on l'applique
dans les détails comment changer de
culture merci Muriel c'est notre
collègue Cédric chevalier puis je vous
laisserai la parole
cherg oui madame la Présidente chers
collègues alors je suis ravi d'avoir
entendu l'ensemble des les interventions
et je partage complètement sur ce qui a
été dit et notamment on sent quand même
une notion de finalement de
déresponsabilisation même si on est
responsable on a envie de porter faire
en sorte il y a l'expression de donner
le singe sur l'épaule du voisin pour
être sûr que ça ne revienne pas dessus
donc et dans tous les domaines
finalement quelque part et qu'au travers
de cette production de norme on souhaite
se protéger et encore plus se
surprotéger moi j'ai dans les
différentses exemples qui ét donné sur
l'impact et notamment l'impact financier
je l'ai vu au travers de ma commune y
compris aussi l'interprétation des
textes en fonction des directions
départementales sur sur tel ou tel sujet
au niveau notamment du logement moi en
fait sur la notion d'impact il y a un
élément qui
m'interpelle le président et je voudrais
lui poser la la question c'est que
est-ce qu'il y a aussi une notion de
transversalité c'estàd que en fait tout
à l'heure vous avez pris l'exemple de
l'urbanisme et quand on change un
certain nombre de d'éléments dans le
code de l'urbanisme ça a forcément des
impacts sur d'autres éléments viennent
en contradiction avec d'autres d'autres
d'autres textes et donc la question de
l'étude d'impact est-ce qu'il est
uniquement financier ou de la nécessité
de de de du côté législatif s'il est
nécessaire de légiférer voir aussi
l'impact sur les autres réglementations
parce que c'est ce qui fait aussi à un
moment donné que plus personne ne
comprend rien au travers des
interprétations des des différents
textes donc c'était un peu la question
par rapport à ça et deuxième élément
effectivement je crois qu'il faut
redonner un peu plus d'agilité
en fonction des territoires une norme
applicable dans tel ou tel territoire
n'est pas forcément applicable dans
l'autre notamment je reviens sur
l'urbanisme et l'exemple qui a été donné
sur le climat résiliance et sur les
décrets je l'ai entendu effectivement on
en arrive à un point de précision qui
n'est pas applicable partout et qui on
se demande d'ailleurs ce que ça vient
faire voilà mais moi c'était plutôt sur
la transversalité avec les autres textes
législatifs et leur
impact carz ensuite nous nous écouterons
président de la MF nous aurons
l'intervention du président wing et nous
ferons une autre petite série de
questions si vous êtes d'accord monsieur
le Président
oui merci bon une réponse très courte
parce que je partage complètement ce qui
vient d'être dit bon comment s'y prendre
moi je crois que c'est un travail de
sensibilisation générale voilà il faut
que chacun de nous là où il est soit euh
devienne davantage conscient peut-être
qu'il ne l'est aujourd'hui de cette
nécessité de de limiter de simplifier
d'utiliser les outils existants et je
n'ai pas évoqué tout à l'heure un point
très important vous avez évoqué madame
ce sont les études expost et je pense
que ce serait intelligent notamment dès
l'étude d'impact de s'obliger à avoir
quelques critères prédéfinis indicateurs
un peu dans l'esprit de de laalolf
d'ailleurs quelques indicateurs qui qui
nous obligent ensuite à regarder si les
objectifs poursuivis ont bien été
atteints euh sur sur sur le terrain et
moi j'ai j'ai fait que parcourir euh la
fameuse étude mais je vais la regarder
plus en détail le travail du Conseil
d'État dit sur le dernier kilomètre mais
là vraiment on est au cœur du sujet
parce que je pense que ce sont les
analyses expos qui permettent de voir si
toutes ces cet arsenal législatif
réglementaire euh qui a été euh voté
puis décidé a vraiment un effet un effet
sur les terrain et si les inconvénients
ne l'pporte pas sur les avantages donc
euh il faut s'obliger on a on a les
moyens sur les études d'expost on a
quand même beaucoup de de de corps
d'inspection on a beaucoup alors
peut-être pas systématique mais sur les
points critiques et aujourd'hui vous
citiez sur l'urbanisme moi à mes yeux
l'urbanisme est vraiment euh devenu euh
aujourd'hui un point un point critique
alors dans l'étude d'impact là je suis
venu avec le
modèle de fiche d'impact alors pour les
textes réglementaires qui est établi par
le Secrétariat général du gouvernement
et effectivement la première question la
première rubrique à remplir c'est l'état
des lieux nécessité de réglementer
présentation du dispositif et comment ce
dispositif s'insère dans la
réglementation euh ou les législations
existantes et notamment avec une
approche transversale transversale c'est
c'est c'est bien l'esprit dans lequel
sont sont construites ces ces études
d'impact mais il faut pas se leurer sur
un point parfois les l'étude d'impact
est très très difficile à à à accomplir
j'étais venu avec un temps d'en parler
mais un exemple de de décret qui est un
décret qui a été pris au terme de je ne
sais plus quelle loi et qui
réglemente la proportion de déchets
verts qu'on peut dorénavant incorporer
dans les boues
euh issu d'épuration euh les pour
permettre le compostage des dites boues
c'est des sujets bon extrêmement
techniques avec des points de vue très
différent donc tout ça ressort bien de
l'étude d'impact mais bon qui doit
décider Infiné et ce que j'ai compris
dans ce texte c'est que peut-être que
euh il fallait davantage écouter le
retour des élus locaux plutôt que des
techniciens ou des entreprises euh
spécialisées dans dans
l'assainissement merci beaucoup euh
monsieur le Président je propose que
nous écoutions euh le président lisnar
qui va nous parler du du comité
législatif réglementaire qui a été créé
à laamf et la raison de de sa création
nous avons eu l'occasion de recevoir son
son président
récemment la machine se lance bonjour à
tous et avant tout merci à Françoise
Gattel en tant que présidente de la
délégation aux collectivités
territoriales et que je salue
chaleureusement et amicalement de même
que je salue son vice-président Rémy
pointerau je ne peux malheureusement pas
être parmi vous physiquement mais je le
suis par la pensée et et surtout par le
soutien total à cette démarche qui vise
à lutter contre cette inflation de
normes cette inflation de complexité de
complication administrative sujet sur
lequel l'Association des maires de
France Françoise Gatel le Sénat moi-même
intervenons depuis longtemps mais qui
devient malheureusement un sujet majeur
puisque quel que soit le secteur
d'activité la bureaucratie excessive est
une des contraintes affronter c'est vrai
dans nos collectivités euh le Sénat
heureusement sous l'impulsion du
Président Larcher que je salue
respectueusement et amicalement porte le
le combat j'allais dire la mano et la
mano avec la MF pour lutter contre ce
phénomène lorsque j'ai eu la chance et
la charge de devenir président de
l'association des mères de France cétait
en novembre 2021 une des première
disposition que j'ai prise a été de
nommer un comité législatif et
réglementaire local qui est co-présidé
par par guoffroid qui a une grande
expérience de législateur et également
par Jean-Pierre Bouquet ce comité
législatif local s'est réuni de faç de
façon régulière mon objectif était de
prendre acte de des effets négatifs de
l'interdiction du cumul des mandats et
de faire en sorte que les préoccupations
du bloc communal des communes des
intercommunalités soient pris en compte
dans la fabrication l'élaboration de la
loi ce travail est en coordination avec
le Comité national d'évaluation des
normes et là aussi j'adresse un salut
amical à Gill carz merci Gill d'avoir
relevé le défi pour que entre la loi et
la réglementation on ait des textes
moins h sol et et et moins bavard
malheureusement le combat est toujours
devant nous et pour cela il faudra outre
le travail qui est mené toutes les
propositions que nous avons faites avec
en parulier Jean-François debas qui
s'est investi dans le comité législatif
qu'il y ait une approche totalement
différente au sommet de l'État ça passe
de la formation des élites à la façon
dont on envisage l'action publique et de
mettre en exerg un principe qu'il faut
redécouvrir en France qui pourtant a
valeur cons institutionnelle qui est
au-delà de la libre administration déjà
importante la subsidiarité que la vie
c'est parfois l'ordre spontané qu'il
faut accepter le risque que la puissance
publique et notamment de l'État doit
cesser d'intervenir a priori pour
délivrer des autorisation surt mais doit
intervenir à postériori qu'on accepte
que les lois se mettent en œuvre de
façon pragmatique et pour cela plutôt
que d'inventer des concepts fumeux et
compliqués de différenciation et autres
que nous fassions valoir tout simplement
la liberté réglementaire et de
transférer le pouvoir réglementaire
d'application des lois hormis sur le
réégalien aux collectivités
territoriales ce serait la grande
réforme de la décentralisation de la
simplification qui ne coûterait pas cher
et qui nous permettrait de concilier
efficacité et liberté par la
responsabilité merci de vos travau et la
MF sera toujours à vos
côtés au président listtin alors je je
vais passer la parole si vous voulez
bien monsieur wedning vous êtes
président de la Conférence des
inspecteurs et auditeurs territoriaux et
je vous remerci vraiment d'être là et
vous allez nous parler de la
cartographie des risques un tout petit
mot en complément de ce que disait
Gilles cares et les questions des des
collègues le fait d'aller faire des
évaluations au plus près du terrain le
président du Sénat souhaite
lancer ce qu'on appelle des une mission
de contrôle territorialisé c'est-à-dire
aller voir dans les territoires au plus
près comment se met en œuvre la loi je
crois que c'est quelque chose
d'extrêmement intéressant on a des
exemples qui nous sont chers avec la
DETR le fond à la vie associative autre
chose merci monsieur le Président
WL merci beaucoup madame la la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs merci pour pour votre
invitation donc quelques mots donc je
représente effectivement la conférence
d'inspecteurs auditeurs territoriaux
alors qu'est-ce que c'est en fait c'est
le regroupement des des personnes en
charge dans les collectivités de
conduire les des inspections dont vous
parliez mais effectivement toutes les
collectivités N sont pas dotées et donc
nous nous efforçons au sein de la
Conférence de de partager mutualiser nos
travaux de manière à aider nos nos
exécutifs à assumer leur fonction et
dans nos échanges ce don on s'est aperçu
C ces dernières années effectivement
c'est ce que vous avez indiqué on est
passé d'une situation où le vide
juridique pouvait présenter un risque
mais plutôt inverse où c'est la
profusion de de de texte et de normes
juridiques qui est plutôt facteur de
risque pour pour nos collectivités donc
cartographier les risques dans nos
collectivités c'est le travail que nous
efforçons de de faire et qui en fait met
en avant une situation où nos exécutifs
dont on a la charge de de de les
conseiller et de et d'essayer de de de
faciliter leur leur action de leur
liberté d'agir comme vous l'avez indiqué
en en préambule de cette matinée et on
s'aperçoit que concrètement je parler un
petit peu de situation expost que vous
évoquez concrètement ce dont on
s'aperçoit c'estement nombre de nos
collectivités aujourd'hui sont en
situation de non conformité donc c'est
vrai que on parle depuis ce matin de
profusion de normes mais à la réalité
c'est qu'on a une profusion de norm mais
aussi une profusion de situation où on
les applique partiellement ou parfois
voit pas parce que soit on les connaît
pas et aujourd'hui la situation c'est
qu'on ne les connaît pas on les recense
pas forcément au niveau local
ou tout simplement on n'a pas la
capacité forcément aussi de les
appliquer ce qui est une vraie situation
et donc on se retrouve à cartographier
ces risques pourquoi par cartographier
les situations nos exécutifs se trouvent
en en situation délicate de de ne pas
appliquer parfois volontairement parce
qu'il faut arbitrer il faut prendre un
risque ou ou de ne pas pouvoir le faire
je vais essayer me forcer donner des
exemples
concrets dans un département par exemple
vous le savez on a la responsabilité de
l'aide sociale à l'enfance les enfants
placés sont sous la responsabilité du
président du conseil départemental qui a
une responsabilité civile mais aussi
pénale
et son administration à la charge
norement de vérifier tous les articles
pas tout la partie B2 du euh
du du quasi judiciaire en fait des
personnes qui travaillent dans les
établissements les foyers où sont
confiés les enfants encore faut-il que
le président du Département reçoive sur
l'administration tous les demandes de
tous les établissements foyers foyer
établissements parfois
euh nationaux parfois qui sont situés
même à l'étranger parfois qui sont
situés dans une autre partie du
territoire et qu'il puissent les
examiner qu'il puissent savoir les
réponses puisque c'est lui qui assume la
responsabilité pénale de de cela donc
aujourd'hui je peux vous assurer que bon
nombre de départements n'ont pas cette
cette vision et n'ont pas mis en place
une organisation parce que elle est
extrêmement complexe à mettre en place
donc c'est une situation concrète qui
montre une norme vol judicieuse
pertinente au début aujourd'hui place en
situation assez compliquer certains
exécutifs on a aussi un impact financier
j'y reviendrai pas on a beaucoup de
situations aussi à à en termes
financiers avec de normes dont
l'application nécessite soit un
investissement lourd vous en avez parlé
en matière d'urbanisme mais aussi en
matière de voirie certains mes
aménagements routiers mais le président
carz on a cité quelques exemples mais
aussi en terme de fonctionnement puisque
parfois certains aménagements un site
implique des des cûts de fonctionnement
pérenn qui vont aggraver la la
contrainte
financière d'autres situations que l'on
retrouve sont peut
parfois bien l'appréhender c'est
l'impact sur les les ressources humaines
des collectivités on voit bien que les
normes dont parle par exemple le
président carz vont appliquer aussi des
recrutements dans les collectivités en
matière d'urbanisme
d'ingénierie mais aussi dans d'autres
sujets en matière de système
d'information or aujourd'hui la
situation est que le marché de l'emploi
fait que les collectivités ont de la
peine à attirer certains profils très
techniques en en matière d'ingénieur
ingénieur travaux publics notamment vous
en AZ parlé mais également en matière de
système d'information mais également en
matière même de de travail social et
donc de par cette contrainte même de de
d'attractivité ou de capacité à recruter
on s en situation compliquée à appliquer
des textes qui nécessitent soit des
études en interne au sein de la
collectivité la norme est abondante et
pourtant pour l'appliquer il faut encore
faire les études au niveau local pour
l'ajuster un plan un parking ne peut pas
se décider au national il faut bien
faire une étude locale d'aménagement
d'implantation du site et encore faut-il
avoir ces compétences donc la profusion
des normes met aussi en difficulté et
accentue ces difficultés des
collectivités sur sur ce
planl j'insiste aussi sur un autre sujet
qui est peu appréhendé qui nous met en
difficulté je reviendrai tout à l'heure
c'est les impacts sur les systèmes
d'information car
effectivement si on modifie une norme
très souvent pour la collectivité encore
faut-il avoir le système d'information
qui permet de de suivre l'application de
la
norme si je prends l'exemple par exemple
des placements d'enfants dont je vous
parlais encore fut système d'information
éventuellement interfacer avec tous ces
établissements médicos-sociaux parfois
en Belgique puisque une grande partie
des enfants confiés à à l'enfance qui
comporte
des des problèmes en terme d'handicap
sont parfois aujourd'hui de de fait
c'est la situation actuelle confier à
d'établissement en Belgique faute de
place en France comment échanger avec
ces établissement en terme de système
d'information pour obtenir ces Casis
judiciaires dont je vous parlais pour
éviter l'envoi postal le mail encore et
cetera donc ça vous paraît extrêmement
peut-être concret mais aujourd'hui ça
implique des développements des
développements et à chaque fois qu'il y
a une norme autant de développement
possible donc on sorte à des difficultés
nombreus sur ce sujet et la conséquence
c'est un service parfois rendu à
l'usager qui est parfois moindre de
moindre qualité une fois la norme
adoptée que sans sans la norme je
reviendrai tout à l'heure le président
carè parlait de la pration de
compensation du handicap récemment il a
une évolution prescrite par la CNSA en
matière de système d'information de
manière à mieux harmoniser au niveau
national le traitement des demandes des
personnes en situation d'handicap mais
la conséquence c'est
que l'intégration dans nos départements
de ce nouveau cahé des charges national
du système d'information a fait que les
dossiers des personnes qui
avaient bénéficier de ces droits par le
passé ne n'ont pas pu être transféré
dans le nouveau système ce qui fait que
le traitement des dossiers de ces
personnes mobilité réduite des problèmes
de vue des problèmes de de
handicap psychique en fait aujourd'hui
le traitement leur dossier est plus long
que par le
passé donc c'est des sujets extrêmement
concrets qui parfois sont mal évoqués et
qui nous met dans nos collectivités dont
vous assurer l'exécutif souvent mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs en de vraies
situations de risque et donc l'enjeu
pour nous est aussi de mieux
cartographier le plus un possible les
conséquences finalement de ces normes
soit de manière exporte une fois
qu'elles sont appliquées mais aussi en
amont pour identifier finalement les
freins à leur application mais aussi les
effets parfois préjudiciables de ces
différentes normes et c'est cela en fait
que l'on essaie de de faire au sein de
de la conférence et c'est cela aussi le
but de ces approches de cartographie des
risques soit expost pour mesurer
finalement les écarts par rapport à la
tenstion initiale mais aussi au moment
de leur de leur
réalisation la difficulté aussi
aujourd'hui que l'on voit en matière de
de cartographie des risques c'est que il
appartient aujourd'hui finalement à
chaque exécutif local finalement de
faire ce travail et de prendre les
arbitrages pour savoir sur quel sujet je
vais agir en premier j'en ai cité
quelquesunsin mais vu la profusion
desénme la difficulté c'est que nos
exécutifs locaux finalement ils
acceptent le ritthme aujourd'hui le
risque c'est eux qui qui le gèrre vont
devoir prendre des décisions pour savoir
ce qu'ils vont traiter quel
investissement je vais réaliser quel
recrutement je vais faire de manière à
appliquer ces normes il faut les
éclairer il faut finalement éclairer
leur décision par ces approches de
cartographie des risques et donc c'est
cela que nous essayons de faire dans les
collectivités où où nous sommes présents
mais chaque collectivité contue de ses
moyens en tout cas sur les 35000 et
queles collectivités peut aujourd'hui
sont en situation
de le faire faute de compét faute de
d'appui aussi sur sur ce
sujet vous
avez
effectivementquiss tout à l'heure
plusieurs hypothèses plusieurs pistes
sur l'origine en fait de ces situations
complexes dont je parle il y en a une
sur lesquell j'insisterai également
c'est la la profusion d'acteurs qui
émettent des normes vous avez
effectivement cité le lislateur il y a
[Musique]
aussi le pouvoir réglementaire comme
vous l'avez indiqué mais je pense qu'il
y a aussi d'autres acteurs qu'il faut
indiquer c'est aussi l'ensemble des
autorités administratives ou différentes
agences vous avez rappelé effectivement
le le rôle important que pourrait avoir
le préfet pour coordonner l'action ces
différents acteurs au niveau
déconcentrés mais aussi on a des acteurs
nationaux comme certaines agences si je
prends la le cas de l'autonomie que
sujet cher aussi à cette assemblée donc
la CNSA elle émet beaucoup de
référentiels beaucoup de normes qui
s'applique au département mais qui ont
un impact direct sur l'organisation de
l'accueil comment je reçois les dossiers
de euh de mes personnes qui veulent
accéder une aide en matière d'aide à
l'autonomie comment mon dossier va être
traité sur quels critères dans quel
délai toutes ces toutes ces règles sont
prescrites par la CNSA donc par des
agences nationales et donc souvent sont
des acteurs qui ne sont pas forcément
bien repérés au moment de la production
des textes mais qui ont un impact direct
sur leur application ce que vous disiez
tout à l'heure alleer voir au plus près
sur le terrain au bout en bout du du
processus d'édiction de la norme comment
la norme est appliquée et du
coup en matière de
risque que les collectivités assument
ces acteurs ont énormément de de respons
abilité donc c'est un sujet
effectivement relativement
important important parce qu'elle a un
impact sur la capacité à faire des des
collectivités un impact sur les moyens
financiers vous l'avez largement évoqué
mais également un impact sur la qualité
du service rendu à l'usager dont parfois
la mesure montre qu'elle est obéré par
la profusion des normes dont vous parlez
dont vous saisissez aujourd'hui
je voulais
ensuite at prendre deux exemples
concrets alors j'ai pas choisi
l'urbanisme parce que j'étais certain
que c'est un sujet qui aura été
largement évoqué par le président carz
donc j'ai pris un sujet sur par exemple
les conflitsintérêts c'est un sujet qui
paraît extrêmement connu hein je ne vais
pas vous présenter ce qu est qu'un
conflit d'intérêt printérêt car vous
connaissez extrêmement bien le sujet
mais on a quand même des situations de
manière concrète qui peuvent impacter le
fonctionnement de nos collectivités
puisque si la loi récent 3DS a essayé de
de simplifier et donner un cadre à ce
sujet on a d'autres quand même
situations où nous avons quand même des
collectivités qui désignent des membres
au sein de différentes structures privé
de nature privée par
association je prends un exemple très
concret vous avez sans doute
dans vos collectivités
parfois des de certains de vos membres
de vos conseils qui vont siéger dans des
mouvements sportifs qui vont siéger dans
des mouvements associatifs à caractère
social qui vont aujourd'hui siéger dans
des mouvements qui vont associatifs qui
vont fédérer les réflexions en matière
d'aménagement pour développer les
circulations douces l'usage du vélo et
souvent vos vos collègues au sein de ces
conseils locaux vous représenter la
collectivité et souvent sont les
personnes les plus
impliquées qui vont siéger dans ces
structures or quand elles vont revenir
dans leur collectivité elles vont devoir
veiller à ne pas participer au débat on
amont d'une décision locale d'une
délibération ce qui peut nuire même à la
qualité finalement des travaux au sein
de ces conseils de ces conseils locaux
ce dont on s'aperçoit aussi c'est que ça
peut être très compliqué donc pour les
les conseils locaux même pour euh pour
gérer euh pour se protéger contre
éventuellement des prises
illégalesintérêt suscité
par ces désignations de membres de ces
conseils au sein de de structures
externes si je prends l'exemple de mon
département une commission permanente
c'est à minima 150 dossiers par
commission permanente si je dois me
prémunir de sous tous les conflits
d'intérêts potentiels encore faut-il le
recenser mais il faut avoir une capacité
à l'identifier ce conflit en amont du
conseil de la commission permanente
alors que parfois les dossiers sont
déposés dans un délai extrêmement réduit
et donc on a une fragilité qui est aussi
accentuée par je dirais la la capacité à
mettre en cohérence un fonctionnement
d'un d'un conseil municipal d'un conseil
département
d'un conseil régional ou d'une
commission permanente où les dossiers
sont extrêmement nombreux les personnes
parfois sièg ponctuellement surtout
quelles sont dans l'opposition dans une
commission sans délégation et qu'elles
ne pensent pas forcément à indiquer leur
mandat autre qu'elle soit qu'elle
représente la collectivité ou pas or
ceci peut avoir un impact important en
terme d'annulation d'une délibération
mais aussi en terme de de qualité
finalement du débat au sein du conseil
pour recueillir les avis les plus les
plus équérés donc il y a un sujet
extrêmement opérationnel qui est comment
j'organise mon processus délibératif au
sein de mon exécutif local au sein de
mon
conseil mais aussi politique pour
pouvoir agir au niveau local avec les
meilleures
compétences donc j'insistais plus parce
que je pense que c'est peut-être mon
rôle ici pour insister sur la mise en
œuvre très concrète très opérationnelle
de ces différentses normes autre sujet
euh très concret c'est la prestation de
compensation du handicap je vais prendre
un exemple aussi très concret qui va
illustrer le nombre d'acteurs qui
interviennent sur ce sujet on a
évidemment le législateur qui intervient
on a évidemment l'autorité réglementaire
mais au niveau local on a deux acteurs
une MDPH qui est un groupement de
l'intérêt public et le département qui
paye la MDPH instruit en amont euh les
droits et euh le Conseil département
mental P
inf au sein de la mph on a plusieurs
plusieurs acteurs on a aussi un autre
acteur dont j'ai parlé qui est la CNSA
dont ces missions sont d'informer les
personnes handicapées donc c'est elle
qui va informer les personnes sur leurs
droits sur comment accéder à cette
prestation on a la CNSA qui fait aussi
de la recherche sur le sujet donc il va
prcrire des orientations au niveau des
départements qui va faire une une
réflexion prospective mais aussi qui a
dans ses statuts et qui le fait au ce
moment en ce moment de prescrire un
règlement en matière de contrôle interne
alors qu'est-ce que c'est en gros c'est
comment les personnes vont voir leur
dossier instruit comment je vais déposer
mon dossier comment mon dossier va être
instruit par qui est-ce que mon dossier
va être instruit par un médecin par un
argothérapeute par un psychologue par un
travailleur social et toutes ces
dispositions sont prescrites par C
règlement
défini par la la
CNSA la conséquence concrète aujourd'hui
c'est des impacts au niveau des
départements mais j'ai c'est l'exemple
que j'ai pris en terme du système
d'information je l'ai évoqué on a pu
chiffrer que par exemple pour mettre en
conformité les départements côté
département côté MDPH pour mettre en
œuvre ces différentes dispositions il a
fallu un temps en humain pour développer
lesation assez conséquent assez lourd
dans un contexte où les départements ont
beaucoup de peine à recruter aujourd'hui
des ingénieur informatique l'autre donc
c'est un coût financier
et et pour
conclure vraiment désolé c'est
épouvantable mais le président Larché
doit nous rejoindre tout à l'heure et je
je voudrais naturellement vous puissiez
être aussi efficace que d'habitude mais
que vous ayez le temps et que nos
collègues a le temps de poser des
questions pardonnez-moi monsieur le
Président non je juste conclure sur ce
point c'est qu'aujourd'hui les
conséquences concrètes on l'a pu mesurer
c'est des délais rallongés en matière
d'instruction d'aide pour les personnes
handicapées parce que le système
d'information n'a pas pu évoluer en
fonction des orgentations définies par
la C donc des des délais
rallongés en terme de maîtrise
éventuellement des sujets de paiement
indu une capacité restreinte parce que
on n'a pas pu aussi mettre en place des
outils adéquats et une situation qui
vous écha vous avez évoqué d'inégalité
de traitement sur le territoire entre
départements donc pour conclure donc
madame la Présidente c'est pour vous
montrer effectivement l'utilité le plus
un nom possible et aussi de manière
expot de bien regarder les risques
auxquels et nos exécutifs sont
confrontés en matière d'application des
normes alors qu'elles sont plus
complexes plus détaillées et plus
nombreuses mais également par rapport à
l'usager que l'on oublie dont finalement
le service dont il bénéficie au niveau
local n'est pas forcément toujours
amélioré par cette profusion de normes
voilà merci madame la Présidente merci
monsieur le Président avant de passer la
parole au président Gérard à qui je
redis le plaisir de de nous retrouver
euh trois de trois points ou deux points
plus exactement sur ce que vous avez dit
l'autonomie et l'indépendance de
nombreuses agences de l'État qui à côté
de l'État viennent imposer un certain
nombre de règles et dans le cadre de
notre not rapport sur les services dé
concentrés nous nous proposons qu'il y
ait un chef d'orchestre unique et la
parole de l'État doit être celle du
préfet qui doit coordonner les avis et
deuxème point ici nous avons un slogan
que nous adorons qui est très simple
très juste et pertinent qui est qui
décide paye or nous savons aujourd'hui
que le la dimension des locaux
accueillant la petite enfance est fixé
au niveau national que la MDPH dont vous
parliez elle fixe de manière très
humaine un certain nombre de
prescriptions notamment dans
l'accompagnement des enfants handicapés
à l'école et notre collèg Cédric bien a
présenter une ppel là-dessus c'est la
MDPH qui fixe la norme et c'est
l'éducation nationale ou la collectivité
sur le temps périscolaire qui finance
donc on a aussi un problème de cohérence
donc monsieur le président Gérard puis
vous madame doming et puis nous aurons
j'espère le temps d'un de de question
parce que je vois que les collègues en
ont beaucoup merci ch monsieur le
Président merci beaucoup madame la
Présidente je rappelle quand même que ce
sujet est quand même un sujet le
président po l'a dit tout à l'heure est
un sujet particulièrement
français Joakim dubalet qu'on apprenait
autrefois à
l'école dans un de ces poèmes disait
France mère des arts des armes et des
lois et déjà sous la Renaissance on
considérait que la la France était le
pays des des lois cet attachement à la
loi cette complexité a étéit dénoncée
sous l'Ancien Régime sous Louis X on
trouve beaucoup de personnes qui
dénoncent la complexité des lois les
États généraux avec les cahiers de
doléance et la révolution c'est aussi ça
et si on a
créé le bicamérisme en France si le
Directoire a créé le bicamérisme et on
est ici dans le temple du bicamérisme
c'était pour pour modérer la passion de
la première assemblée en matière
législative et donc le Sénat se retrouve
complètement dans son rôle on disait que
le Conseil des 500 faisait des lois avec
la passion et que les conseils des
anciens devaient les examiner avec la
raison et donc on retrouve un peu votre
rôle alors j'envens au Conseil d'État
qui qui a fait deux deux études sur ce
sujet récente une en 2016 dont on a déjà
eu l'occasion de parler sur lesquelle je
vais aller vite et puis la dernière sur
l'usager du premier au dernier kilomètre
en 2016 on s'était intéressé au thème
simplification et qualité du droit et on
avait vu que la norme correspondait
aussi hélas la complexité d'un monde
plus ouvert euh à la complexité des
individus on voit bien que la famille
d'aujourd'hui c'est plus la famille
d'autrefois il y a des beaucoup de cas
particulier la volonté de répondre à
tout euh surtout en l'absence de
ressources budgétaires je crois que céit
je me souviens très bien un jour j'avais
déjeuné avec le sénateur lombert et le
sénateur Boulard hlas décédé et et le
sénateur Bouard me disait vous savez en
France quand on n pas d'argent on se
paye de mot et au fond la loi c'était
c'était un peu ça c'est la volonté de
répondre à tout problème c'est l'enjeu
des débats publics imaginez une campagne
présidentielle dans laquelle les
candidats disent voter pour moi quel que
soit leur parti je ne ferai aucune loi
bah ils seraiit pas élu donc on sait
bien que tout ce qui est annoncé doit
doit être suivi des faits et puis il y a
cette passion française absolue de
égalité dans laquelle il faut que chacun
se retrouve avec en pensant qu'il est
exactement l'égal de l'autre et que les
lois doivent être appliqué de façon
uniforme alors tout ça s'ajoute des
phénomènes plus récents les besoins de
consultation plus vous consultez plus
vous accroisser la norme parce qu'il
faut tenir compte de ce que vous avez
consulté on l'a dit tout à l'heure c'est
Monsieur vening qui l'a dit la
multiplication des structures
administratives toutes productrices de
normes j'ajoute que la numérisation dont
on nous a présenté le fait qu'elle était
utile à ministre tion que tout allait
plus vite et ca est un facteur
d'accroissement desnmes pour une raison
très simple c'est que quand vous faites
du traitement de texte vous recopiez et
hop vous ajouter avant quand on ajoutait
un mot à la main qu'il fallait écrire
taper et ben on en a ajouté moins c'est
tout simple et puis vous avez la
responsabilité pénale des
décideurs qui cherch effectivement vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure à propos de du
covid et d'autres à se retrancher
derrière des textes qui du coup der
renent plus long résultat on a des
normes toujours plus compliquées
toujours interprété par des juges et
après comme on n'est pas content de
l'interprétation on revient dessus on la
recorrige tout ça nous créer un handicap
de dans la compétition internationale
l'Inspection Générale des Finances
estime que le coût des normes françaises
spécifique c'est à peu près 3 % du PIB
ce quand même pas rien et nous avions
fait beaucoup de propositions à ce sujet
deux principalement ont été retenu dans
de notre rapport en 2016 d'abord
maintenant on mesure les statistiques de
la norme le secrétaire général du
gouvernement publ qui chaque année au
printemps un indicateur suivi des normes
et puis la révision constitutionnelle de
2008 sur les études d'impact qui permet
de faire ses études même si on sait bien
que pour l'instant l'interprétation
donné le consetionnel est assez
distanciée alors sur les
chiffres en 2002 comme chacun sait nul
ne peut ignorer la loi mais pour ne pas
ignorer la loi il faut si vous comptez
toutes les lois enur
5800000 mots 3100000 codifiés 2700000
non codifiés en
2023 ça c'était en 2002 en 2023 14
millions de mots dans les lois on a
presque triplé si on prend les codes
c'est le slide suivant le code du
travail en 2002 4986 articles
aujourd'hui
11179 le code de l'urbaniste 1459
2361 le code de l'environ environnement
2002 1000 articles aujourd'hui
7000 le Code de la Santé 4930
aujourd'hui 12800 et si je reviens sur
le code de l'environnement en mot il y a
2002 c'était 100000 mots aujourd'hui
c'est 11000 mots en 20 ans on a on est
passé de 100000 à 1 million de mots dans
le C et puis le président poou en
parlait tout à l'heure si je prends les
lois si je prends par exemple les lois
qui ont été déposé les projets de loi
général je parle pas des lois sur les
ratification des traités en 2022 elle
comportait 435 articles à la sortie 1142
à la suite d'amendement soit du
gouvernement soit soit des
parlementaires voilà notre premier
rapport sur le second rapport j'essaie
d'aller vite madame la Présidente comme
vous me l'avez suggéré l'usager du
premier au dernier kilomètre rapport que
nous avons publié cette année nous
notons que les usagers ont changé dans
leur rapport avec l'administration en
particulier dans les deux dernières
décennies autrefois on avait une
approche essentiellement uniforme des
administrés considérés comme quasiment
interchangeable des services publics qui
étai hérité du 19e siècle aujourd'hui on
a des personnes qui ne sont plus des
usagers mais qui veulent être des
bénéficiaires de politique publique et
ces bénéficiaires de politiqu publique
leur diversité leur hétérogénité n'a pas
cessé de croître l'administration aussi
a changé la décentralisation l'ouverture
de servic publics à la concurrence
l'organisation administrative est
devenue beaucoup plus complexe
l'émiettement des acteurs on en a parlé
les agences les opérateurs privés les
associations et puis la numérisation je
reviens souvent là-dessus mais la
numérisation a éloigné de
l'administration et de l'état certains
usagers dans les campagnes de certains
usagers qui personnes âgées qui ne
savent pas du tout utiliser ces
techniques là et puis l'administration a
tendance à faire peser la
complexité sur les usagers les normes
sont plus complexes parfois
contradictoires je vous montrerai tout à
l'heure ure l'affaire de laabribus alors
on nous avons fait quatre propositions
essentiellement un il faut sortir du 100
% numérique parce que si on continuer à
se donner comme objectif 100 % numérique
on accroîtra une diversité avec des
personnes capables et des personnes très
vulnérables qui en sont pas capables il
faut concevoir l'action publique pour
atteindre le dernier kilomètre
c'est-à-dire que c'est à
l'administration d'absorber la
complexité et non pas le reporter sur
l'usager il faut assurer autant
d'énergie à faire fonctionner les
services existants qu'à faire de la
nouveauté à force de faire de la
nouveauté à travers de nouvelles
politiques publiqu on oublie la
maintenance des réseaux on oublie les
trains les conductions d'action potable
l'état des ponts les urgences des
hôpitaux et cetera tout ça suppose
d'écrire différemment les normes en
fixant des principes généraux et en
laissant au pouvoir réglementaire ou à
la négociation collective le soin de
régler les choses alors je voudrais
terminer par vous montrer l'étude que
nous avons fait sur l'abribus il y a
juste un abribus quand vous sortez du
Conseil d'État donc vous y penserez en
sortant un brebus élément de mobilier
urbain on peut passer sur le slide euh
qui euh dont le bon usage doit implique
de prendre en compte sa visibilité sa et
son et son positionnement et sa
lisibilité il y a une erreur c'est sa
libilité sa visibilité sa visibilité et
son et son positionnement alors qui est
compétent pour imp planter un abribus ça
est suivant je
crois si c'est la voie départementale
c'est le conseil départemental si c'est
l'arrêt se trouve sur une voie d'intérêt
c'est la communauté d'agloot si c'est
une voie communale c'est la commune mais
quel que soit l'organisme Les planans de
déplacement urbain doivent dire où sont
les abribus et doivent même être
compatibles avec le volet intermodalité
du schéma régional d'aménagement de
développement durable et d'égalité d'
terroire le stradet du conseil régional
voilà alors ensuite vous avez les règles
d'accessibilité pour la
bribus il faut que euh le
trottoir d'abord
euh satisfa à plusieurs critères avec
deux chemin un premier pour
l'embarquement entre l'abri le trottoir
qui doit êtreune largeur minimale de 90
cm le second pour la circulation des
piétons entre la brille bâtie d'une
largeur minimale de 1,40 mais si le
trottoir ne permet pas ces de largeur
laabribus peut être adossé à un bâtiment
mais dans ce cas-là il faut une largeur
minimale d'un,40 entre le bâti et le nez
du
trottoir il faut aussi prévoir la
circulation des personnes à mobilité
réduite je crois que la circulation du
coup une aire de rotation d' 1, 50 de
diamètre doit permettre la manœuvre d'un
fauteuil roulant qui utilise le
dispositif d'aide à l'embarquement
jusqu'au débarquement si l'arrêt de
transport est surélevé de plus de 26 cm
de hauteur de la chaussée une bande
d'éveil de vigilance conforme au norme
en vigueur doit être implanté et le
marquage au sol doit être en forme d'une
ligne de zigzag jaune pour un bus
conerment une instruction ministérielle
complaté par un arrêté alors après vous
avez les signaléthtique c'est la slide
suivant euh qui demande que certaines
informations doivent être soit doublé
par un signal sonore qu'ell soit
facilement compréhensible lisible en
toutes conditions les caractères dont
une hauteur de 1 CM50 au minimum pour
une lecture proche 15 cm pour une
lecture à 4 m et de 20 cm pour une
lecture à 6 cm la lettre et le numéro
identifiant le numéro de Bu est indiqué
en caractère de 12 cm de hauteur au
minimum et de couleur contrastée par
rapport au fond et enfin si je fais si
vous utilisez la brbus à la fin
publicitaire selon l'objet du contrat
selon son caractère vousz passer soit un
marché public soit une convention
d'occupation de domain public soit un
contrat de concession mais c'est pas
fini parce que les abribus c'est aussi
pour les enfants et donc vous pouvez
accueillir des enfants qui vont à
l'école au collège et vous savez que
depuis la loi notre ce sont les régions
qui sont
organisatri des transports mais
l'intercommunalité peut assurer
l'organisation le fonctionnement dans
les conditions définies par convention
avec la région mais si c'est les élèves
handicapés alors il faut aller voir le
département qui est compétent pour le
les départements mais pour les points
d'arrêt de suivant de chargement et de
déchargement des enfants en transport
scolaire c'est le
maire qui est responsable de tout ça
ENF lorsqu'un stationnement est prévu le
stationnement d'un autre véhicule
interdit ça ça paraît quand même normal
et la signalisation de C routière à
proximité de point d'arrêt doit faire
l'objet dit un texte d'une attention
particulière qui soit sé en
agglomération en agglomération
alors après il y a y a ceux qui
conduisent les bus SL suivant chauffeur
de bus durée du travail texte européen
sur les alors vous avez les taexes
Européens le code de transport le code
du travail vous arrivez donc SL suivant
durée du temps du travail travail
quotidien doit pas dépasser 10h mais
sous certaines conditions aller jusqu'à
12h de fois par semaine la durée du
travail abdomadaire ne pouvait pas
passer en moyenne 44 heur sur 12
semaines puis vous avez la dur la durée
de temps de conduite et de repos avec
une pause de 45 minutes après après un
temps de conduite de 40 he 30 mais la
limite quotidienne étant limitée à 9h
pouvant être porté à 10h deux fois par
semaine puis vous avez le temps de pause
alors le temps de pause c'est encore un
autre système puisque il faut vérifier
que personne ne travaille plus de 6 he
consécutives sans pause mais lorsque le
travail de quotidien est interrompu par
une pause au moins 30
minutes si par exemple le total 10 he de
travail compris entre 6 et 9h et il doit
être interrompu par une pause au moins
45 minutes lorsque le total des heur de
travail est supérieur à 9h mais vous
pouvez diviser les pauses c'est les
texte qui les disent en période d'une
durée d'au moins 15 minutes chacune et
puis vous avez le repos quotidien avec
le la durée le duré minéale bon j'arrête
là
euh vous vous voyez ce que vous voyez à
quoi conduit la réglementation et la
norme et je pense que il faut que on a
tous une responsabilité les uns et les
autres il faut en être conscient mais il
y a un moment il faudra arrêter quoi
voilà madame la Présidente merci
monsieur monsieur le Président chers
collègues vous comprendrez pourquoi nous
apprécions beaucoup la coopération avec
le Conseil d'État n'hésitez pas à en
parler alors je je pense nous le disions
éclise que peut-être nous allons faire
une sorte de petite fiche avec ce qui
pourrait être un
sketch si ça n'était pas aussi
dramatique parce que
l'arrêbs je pense que tous nos
collèguees en a entendu parler notamment
quand on est dans No petites communes
voilà il y a ce scénario ce qui fait que
l'autre jour moi j'ai rencontré un mère
qui me dit j'ai une mère de famille qui
m'a demandé un arrê bus son enfant avait
4 ans il a aujourd'hui 13 ans fort
heureusement il continue à aller à
l'école mais on n' pas géré ça c'est
vraiment je ne sais pas si je dois vous
remercier pour nous raconter des choses
pareilles monsieur le Président vraiment
merci je m'en excuse moi-même mais c'est
ça ça parle vraiment merci monsieur le
Président je pense que nous aurons une
séquence tout aussi forte euh voir voilà
si votre malette contient ce que vous
nous apportez d'habitude j'ai des
cadeaux je suis comme le Père Noël j'ai
des cadeaux dans ma hautete alors tout
d'abord merci madame la Présidente pour
votre invitation
voilà je tiens effectivement moi aussi à
saluer cette initiative parce que je
vais prendre un exemple pour rebondir
sur ce qui a été dit
auparavant moi j'ai eu la chance et le
bonneur de suivre des études de droit
pas très loin d'ici et en première année
de droit je pense dans une des premiers
cours un de mes professeurs nous a dit
avant toute chose sachez qu'il n'existe
pas de vide juridique et c'est resté je
pense que c'est quasiment une des seules
choses que j'ai retenu de mes premières
années de droit j'avoue il n'existe pas
de vide juridique et ça je pense que
c'est très important quand on on se
destine à être juriste mais je pense
qu'il faudra le dire à tout le monde
effectivement euh donc comme l'an
dernier j'interviens pour témoigner de
l'inflation normative et de ses
conséquences du point de vue euh des
juristes de collectivité puisque que moi
mon travail consiste à dépouiller
notamment le Journal Officiel tous les
matins euh en effet donc le FEF d'allose
édite un mensel dont je suis rédactrice
en chef l'actualité juridique des
collectivités territoriales et étant
donné tout ce que vous avez entendu ce
matin vous imaginez la charge de travail
que cela représente pour moi euh et puis
nous éditons énormément de code beaucoup
je pense que je suis pas capable de de
les compter mais nous en avons un
certain nombre que vous connaissez le
code général des collectivités
territoriales tout d'abord le code
général de la Fonction publique que je
n'ai pas apporté et puis le code de
l'urbanisme qu'on a beaucoup évoqué mais
j'aurais pu vous parler du code de
l'environnement du code rural parce que
oui effectivement en ce moment c'est
d'actualité il y a beaucoup beaucoup de
code du code de la commande publique
aussi puisqu'on l'a évoqué donc nous
chez le FEF d'os chez dalos on on à
travers la la revue à travers les codes
on est les premiers spectateurs alors ça
un côté un peu passif mais on on est
aussi les premiers décrypteurs des
textes qui sont publiés chaque jour jour
euh donc je vais procéder par
démonstration
euh l'an dernier je peux vous dire ce
sont des Pava Pava à l'appuie je vous
montrais que les codes étaient devenus
obèses et pour certains même ils ont
dépassé le nombre de page possi euh
c'est le cas du code de la santé
publique ça va vous paraître étonnant
que je vous apporte celui-là en premier
mais dorénavant il est publié en deux
tomes je vous explique je vous le montre
voilà on a dû créer un coffret
spécial voilà c'est le code de la santé
publique c'est le plus gros euh pour
être très honnête on on avait jamais
fait ça euh on a été obligé de le le
diviser en deux euh parce que c'est
impossible de publier un code aussi gros
aujourd'hui matériellement euh et puis
je pense c'est difficile de le vendre
aussi estce que ça coûte très très cher
euh je le rangerai plus tard je vous le
laisse ici
euh
on est donc bien loin du code de poche
ou du petit code
d'Allos voilà puisque ça c'était le nom
initial de la collection ça s'appelait
le petit code d'allose et j'ai apporté
pour faire la démonstration du petit
code
d'allose le code de des sociétés al ça
nous concerne pas directement ici mais
bon le Code des sociétés de
1959 voilà qui tient dans ma poche c'est
donc le code de poche par rapport au
code de la santé publique voilà celui-là
je le garde c'est c'est le plus ancien
que j'ai pu trouver il est magnifique
voilà euh donc la slide qui qui apparu
là c'est pour vous montrer en
1982 le code de l'urbanisme comptait 650
pages je vous le montre aussi 650 pages
voilà le magnifique petit code de
l'urbanisme de 1982 il en compte
d'énavant
3630 voilà je
je je vous le montre tout le monde peut
voir la différence
3630 en 96 en 1996 le code général des
collectivités territoriales il comptait
pages je vous parlais de H du Père Noël
c'est un peu ça euh 620 pages il est
dans rénavant de 3200 ça c'est le
dernier millésim celui de 2024 qui est
sorti il y a pas longtemps
voilà donc 2500 pages supplémentaires et
puis donc le code de la santé publique
en deux tomes compte plus de 4000 pages
alors bien sûr le code de la santé
publique vous vous comprenez pourquoi il
fait 4000 pages hein depuis la la la
crise sanitaire
euh faut que je vous explique autre
chose on a joué sur le papier on a joué
sur l'po on a joué sur les marges mais
on a joué sur le contenu en fait un code
ça ça contient l'ensemble des textes
applicables dans un domaine particulier
que nous réunissons nous en tant
qu'édutire euh nous anotons avec de la
jurisprudence c'està-dire que nous
relayons la jurisprud la plus pertinente
sur le sujet grâce à des auteurs et puis
nous
commentons ces textes et les
commentaires permettent de
contextualiser les textes et de mieux
les comprendre dans le code de la santé
publique rien que les textes juste les
texte et un peu de jurisprudence c'est
tout ce qui rentre c'est uniquement ce
qui rentre dans les plus de 4000 pages
tous les commentaires ont été mis en
ligne c'estàd qu'aujourd'hui on est dans
l'incapacité de de d'expliquer sur le
papier euh la valeur le contenu le
contexte de de tous les textes
applicables en droit de la santé
publique donc vous vous imaginez même
nous on y arrive pas en fait voilà alors
tout ça c'est très parlant voilà c'est
qu'un aspect de l'inflation normative
mais c'est vrai que c'est très frappant
donc c'est la preuve par l'image voilà
eu pour en revenir sur ce qu'on ce que
vous évoquiez tout à l'heure monsieur
Gérard quand je suis arrivée chez dalos
on m'a raconté que auparavant on mtait à
jour les codes en découpant au ciseau le
Journal officiel que nous recevions
chaque jour et on
collait avec de la colle effectivement
et on faisait la mise à jour chaque
semaine du code avec une paire de
ciseaux et de la colle autant vous dire
qu'aujourd'hui c'est pas tout à fait le
cas sur le code rural l'année dernière
il y a eu plus de 1400 fichiers de mise
à jour on est donc très très loin de la
paire de ciseaux et et de la colle et ce
serait plus possible aujourd'hui voilà
donc je reviendrai pas sur les raisons
multiples et en de l'inflation normative
parce que c'est pas le thème de cette
matinée mais moi je je je parlerai
effectivement de de de difficultés qui
sont liés à à à cette inflation au
manque de lisibilité des textes nous on
le voit aux difficultés d'application ça
vous l'avez beaucoup évoqué et puis de
l'instabilité vraiment l'instabilité
constante de la norme parce que nos
codes là je vous ai sorti des codes de
papier qui sont mésimés qui sont annuels
mais nous on est on fait une mise à jour
quotidienne en fait des codes en ligne
et et aujourd'hui un code siôt sorti je
sais pas si je peux vous le dire mais
vous le savez ENF c'est une évidence
c'est tout sorti il est déjà en partie
périmé
donc les commentaires les annotations de
jurisprondance sont toujours pertinentes
mais mais les textes il faut toujourser
vérifier en ligne sur lesg France ou sur
nos bases de données bien sûr mais si le
texte il est toujours à jour puis il
change sans arrêt en fait donc
voilà je vous disais on va revenir sur
les chiffres parce que les chiffres
toujours intéressant c'est la slide
suivante voilà je me suis permis de
mettre un la gaff parce que c'est un peu
ça des fois on a un peu ce sentiment là
surtout là moi aujourd'hui HH si on
s'entient à la loi et pour se baser sur
des chiffres donc 56 lois ont été
promulguées en 2023 il y en avait 74 en
70 donc il y en a moins il y en a eu
moins l'année dernière mais les les les
lois elles sont de plus en plus grosse
on en a parlé effectivement donc 177
articles pour la loi allure 234 pour la
loi hlan hein donc l'urbanisme
effectivement en tête et 305 euh pour la
loi climat et résilience et donc en
cascade hein tous les textes
d'application euh on parle de de normes
et donc des textes d'application moi je
je vais illustrer mes propos et puis je
j'irai très vite là-dessus sur le
Journal officiel de décembre 2023 parce
que pour moi ça a été un immense plaisir
de de de clôturer l'année 2023 avec ce C
Jio euh il pas besoin d'aller chercher
très très loin pour souffrir en fait le
praticien sait que de nombreuses
décisions sont rendues par le Conseil
d'État en juillet chez nous on dit que
le Conseil d'État vide ses tiroirs mais
c'est l'expression qu'uti et que le GI
de DESC et et généralement bien à
chalandé et donc 2023 n'a pas dérogé à
cette règle on a relevé 204 textes 204
textes intéressants les collectivités
publiés en décembre et 45 plus
particulièrement significatifs selon
l'Observatoire smacle des risques de la
vie territoriale faut mesurer l'impact
que ça représente en un mois il y a donc
204 textes qui ont été publiés
boom il y en a même eu 51 juste entre le
22 décembre et le 30 21 décembre c'est
pas de trêve des confuseurs pour les
juristes de collectivité boom faut lire
son Jo tous les matins alors certains
sont sans doute anecdotique d'autres
beaucoup moins moi si je men'entiens aux
loi je vais vous citer la loi plein
emploi qui entraîne des changements
majeurs en matière de RSA notamment pour
ce qui intéresse les collectivités la
loi visant à réduire les inégalités
territoriales pour les ouvertures de
casinos la loi Val tout sur les déserts
médicaux la loi relative aux services
express régionaux métropolitain la loi
de fin
bon c'est quand même un peu important et
puis la dernière loi publiée en 2023
last but not leist on va dire la loi
visant à revaloriser le métier de
secrétaire de mairie donc très très loin
d'être anecdotique dernière loi publiée
de 2023 voilà donc des gros texes très
nombreux et qui sont parfois publiés
inextrémiste
oserais-je dire c'est le cas du décret
portant modification du code de
l'environnement toujours l'environnement
relative à la publicité aux enseignes et
aux pré-enseignes qui a été publié le 31
décembre
pourah une application dès le lendemain
voilà alors bien sûr on peut anticiper
hein tous ces textes ça s'anticipe
largement dans les dans les collectivité
he c'est facile de dire c'est publié le
31 pour le lendemain mais enfin quand
même bon voilà c'est je peux aussi vous
donner l'exemple du décret du 26
décembre en matière RH qui modifie les
dispositions statutaires relatives à la
promotion interne dans la fonction
publique territoriale dont les
disposition était applicable 4 jours
après sa publication et je précise
c'était toujours entre noël et jour de
l'an donc c'est bon un peu particulier
comme période donc voilà moi j'ai pu
échanger avec des directeurs de de des
affaires juridiques de collectivité qui
m'ont tous qu'ont tous reconnu que comme
disait monsieur venling un certain
nombre de textes ne sont pas appliqués
ces textes en grande partie ceux qui ont
été publiés en décembre ne le sont
toujours pas euh je passerai sur un
certain nombre de choses il y avait la
slide
suivante euh qui reprenait en fait euh
les chiffres les indicateurs de suivi de
l'activité normative que Monsieur Gérard
a déjà évoqué il y a des chiffres
édfiants effectivement sur le nombre de
pages publiées au Journal officiel en
2004 33 plus de 33000 presque 34 en 2022
71000 donc voilà moi j'ai P pomp P pompe
euh donc si pour en revenir à la norme
on va dire qu'il y a un manque de
lisibilité de certains texes qui procèd
par renvoi vers d'autres textes qui
nécessite des rectificatifs moi pour en
avoir discuté avec beaucoup de mes
collègues beaucoup me disent qu'il y a
beaucoup de de rectificatif voté enfin
publiés et puis parfois des entrées en
vigueur différées et modulé au sein d'un
même texte voilà donc je je vais
conclure rapidement
euh ajouter à tout cela des textes
présentés en urgence si on prend les
décrets de novembre
2023 sur les transferts le transfert de
la gestion des dig nomaniales aux
communes et groupement concernés par la
gimapi ces décrets ont été pris 9 ans
après la loi ayant prévu ce transfert
mais seulement 2 mois avant le transfer
lui-même je crois que le CN a eu
l'occasion d' d' d'en parler et vous
pouvez imaginer qu'ela en fait de la
question politique qui est pas du tout
mon sujet on peut s'interroger sur la
qualité toujours la qualité de la norme
euh et
donc je vais juste citer un auteur en
2005 qui disait s'interroger sur la
qualité sa qualité la qualité de la loi
comme on le ferait de n'importe quel de
n'importe quel produit marchand c'est
introduire le doute sur son fondement
même voilà donc on finit avec
montescueux les lois inutiles
affaiblissent les lois nécessaires ne
l'oublions pas merci si
merci
beaucoup chère Madame de on dit toujours
que il y a le choc des photos si je puis
dire et que je pense que si on avait si
chaque contributeur à la fabrique de la
loi et nous sommes nombreux avait ce
genre de rappel dans son bureau forme
c'est c'est voilà à chaque fois moi ça
me fait le même effet merci merci
beaucoup merci beaucoup à à chacun je
propose propose de céder la parole tout
de suite à nos intervenants en vous
remerciant tous vraiment de la qualité
de vos interventions et de la manière
dont vous
appréhendez comme nous la finalité
l'usage l'entrave ou le bien-être que
génère la norme à partir d'exemples très
concrets donc il y a deux demandes de
parole notre collègue Cédric Vial puis
notre collègue Cédric
chevalier et peut-être d'autres
n'hésitez pas merci présidente Pr prise
de parole courte mais je voudrais juste
si vous me permettez
contribuer à l'intervention de de
Patrick Gérard ce qui me rappellera
l'époque où où déjà j'écrivais pour lui
où je j'avais l'honneur de de travailler
sous sa responsabilité euh concernant
les abribus puisque moi j'ai j'ai été en
tant que maire et et pendant un peu plus
de 10 ans responsable d'un syndicat qui
gérait le transport scolaire qui était
une ao2 c'est encore une une complexité
supplémentaire CIT organisateur de de
transport secondaire et et vous rappelez
qu'on pourrait rajouter aussi le
règlement du transport scolaire euh
puisque dans le règlement du transport
scolaire en je vais parler de l'exemple
de de de la Savoie par exemple il faut
se enfants pour pouvoir créer un circuit
de transport scolaire donc et par contre
il faut au moins 4 enfants pour pouvoir
créer un un arrêt sur sur ce circuit ces
quatre enfants on prend évidemment en
compte non pas la distance il faut une
distance de de 3 km par rapport à
l'établissement de rattachement qui
n'est pas forcément l'établissement dans
lequel les l'lève est scolarisé mais
bien l'école l'établissement dans lequel
il aurait dû être scolarisé s'il avait
respecté la la carte scolaire et on
prend non pas la distance par rapport à
l'abribus mais par rapport à la
résidence de l'enfant qui peut-être du
du coup parfois inférieur au 3 km qui
sont nécessaires même si l'abribus lui
est supérieur à la règle des 3 km bien
sûr on fait une exception si les enfants
sont scolarisés en primaire puisque là
on peut descendre à 2 km5 et 2 km si euh
la collectivité de rattachement prend 50
% en charge le le le coût de de de cet
élève qui là peut être pris en compte
dans le bus selon le nombre de de places
disponibles puisque la taille du bus
n'est n'est pas garantie par rapport au
nombre d'élèves euh pr pris transporté
mais par rapport au nombre d'élèves
ayant droit transportter c'est ce qui
est une une petite nuance bien sûr dans
ce transport il faut mettre un
accompagnateur s'il y a plus de 6
enfants euh qui ont moins de 6 ans euh
sur une partie du du trajet même si le
6e enfant ne monte que sur un arrêt qui
est qui intervient en cours en cours du
du trajet et on pourrait en citer
beaucoup d'autres si votre enfant est
handicapé vous l'avez dit si l'enfant
est handicapé vous ne dépendez pas de ce
circuit mais mais de la région avec un
un donc un circuit qui est mis en place
spécifiquement pour votre enfant en
règle générale un taxi qui vient le
chercher par contre si vous avez si cet
enfant a un frère lui ne peut pas monter
dans le taxi il doit aller prendre le le
le le bus à l'arrêt qui peut être situé
parfois à une certaine distance de de de
chez lui bien sûr quand vous êtes dans
sur un département comme comme c'est mon
cas sur une situation limitrophe avec le
un département voisin ce qui dans mon
cas c'est ler le règlement peut-être
différent euh dans les matières de prise
en charge ou ou ou de financement et et
je je m'arrêterai là mais c'était juste
pour si vous souhaitez monter un
spectacle je je seraiis ravi de de de
contribuer à son écriture à vos
côtés
euh notre
collègue Cédric chevalier vous avez la
parole chers collègu merci madame la
Présidente écoutter notre collègue
Cédric Vial je me dis que entre ce qu'a
dit Patrick Gérard CLA demain qui est
lui-même il y avait un jeu télévisé qui
s'appelait le kalalumox de des kalalumox
c'était ça où il y avait des règles qui
faisaient à peu près ça sans voilà non
mais au-delà de ça et j'ai noté aussi le
côté obèse des lois qui a été indiqué je
savais pas que que l'obésité aussi
pouvait attaquer le le régime législatif
parce que c'était indiqué dans les dans
le slide de tout à l'heure moi la
question que je me pose par rapport à ce
que disais tout à l'heure Patrick
gerérrard et finalement la réflexion
j'ai au sens large j'ai bien compris que
ce qui nous était aussi demandé c'est à
un moment donné une forme de PAE
législative et de recul finalement sur
les choses et que ça serait pas mal
aussi à un moment donné de de prendre ce
temps de respiration pour pour bien
comprendre moi j'ai une question
beaucoup plus large c'est de me dire
est-ce qu'à un moment donné je je je
pose la question de manière totalement
naïve est-ce que l'intelligence
artificielle est un pourrait être demain
un outil pour faire émerger on va dire
ces contradictions et être peut-être un
outil au service de la simplification
voilà c'est c'est une question que je me
pose parce que aujourd'hui et je voulais
poser la question à Patrick g c'est
combien de temps lui avait pris en terme
de recherche le rien que le les slides
sur laabribus parce que c'est aussi une
recherche de différents texes et il y a
peut être un élément de réponse ou à
contrario peut-être un élément de
complexité merci merci à vous deux qui
souhaite alors vous êtes spécialiste des
bus nous l'avons compris il existe des
autorités organisatrice de transport moi
je pense que vous pourzêre le
président merci madame la Présidente non
mais je vois que ce que je vous ai
expliqué était encore insuffisant
puisque ce qu'a dit le sénateur Vial
montre que on éétait pas allé jusqu'au
bout de jusqu'au bout du sujet il faudra
il faudrait alors pour répondre à
l'autre question monsieur le sénateur
sur la l'affaire d'intelligence
artificielle moi je ne suis pas sûr que
si vous posez une question à
l'intelligence artificielle sur tel ou
tel problème elle ne vous répondent pas
il faut faire une loi donc j'ai plutôt
la crainte que ça soit encore un facteur
d'accroissement des normes plutôt qu'un
facteur de de restriction
des faudra faudra être extrêmement
vigilant sur ce sujet je crois
nous
étions nous étions au au question de
enfin Cédric Val ça n'était pas vraiment
une question c'était un complément et un
autre épisode à votre histoire sur sur
la bribus que nous raconterons au
président Larcher je crois que vous avez
répondu à la question de de notre
collègue Cédric chevalier sur
l'intelligence artificielle c'est un
sujet qui nous préoccupe à la délégation
parce que nous voyons aujourd'hui qu'il
y a des recommandations qui sont faites
au préfet pour recourir à l'intelligence
artificielle pour effectuer le contrôle
de
l'égalité et donc cela veut dire que
l'intelligence artificielle est entrée
dans le le fonctionnement de nos
collectivités de l'État et que nous
avons choisi d'accomplir une mission sur
le sujet pour identifier contrôler
essayer de de enfin de mesurer les
effets de ça et et les conséquences et
dernier petit point chers collègues les
excellents slides que vous avez vu sont
toute sur
déméire voilà depuis quelques instants y
a-t-il un souhait de complément de
réponse avant que je ne passe la parole
au président
Larcher ce silence d'aquessement
m'impressionne monsieur le Président je
je vous
remercie je vous
remercie de de nous honorer de de votre
présence donc nous savons l'attachement
qu'il est vôtre et votre détermination
nation a contribué à la frugalité
pertinente de la fabrique de de la loi
puisque je rappelais que nous avons le
Sénat a signé avec le gouvernement une
charte d'engagement l'an dernier sur une
meilleure fabrique de de de la loi nous
voyons combien les normes sont le sujet
majeur de préoccupation des élus locaux
et nous voyons comment l'actualité
aujourd'hui de manière générale s'en
emparle dans tous les domaines et
combien la norme entrave le pouvoir
d'agir le le ralenti génère des coûts et
a des résultats contre-productifs donc
avec le le premier vice-président remémi
pointerau qui est en charge de la on va
dire de la enfin de la simplification
nous uvrons depuis la mise en place
enfin depuis la signature de cette
charte à mettre en œuvre nos souhaits et
donc ce matin nous avons une réunion
extrêmement intéressante et je remercie
les collègues qui sont venus de toutes
les et les commissions avec des
intervenants de grande qualité qui je
crois
partagent totalement notre souci parce
que ce combat est un combat collectif de
prise de conscience de sensibilisation
aussi de nos
compatriotes qui par des excès de
d'exigence et d'addiction un peu à la
judiciarisation nous amène les uns et
les autres à surcharger le flux normatif
que nous savons aussi il faut le dire
que la
complexité du monde fait que la norme
sobre est un exercice difficile et puis
cher président tous ces témoignages de
nos intervenants étent absolument
passionnant et puis nous vous
raconterons un jour mais Cédric Vial
connaît la totalité de l'histoire
l'exemple qui je crois peut nous aider à
guérir de tous nos mots qui est celui de
l'installation d'un abribus quand cela
est nécessaire pour permettre à un
enfant d'aller à à l'école je pense
qu'il vaudrait mieux supprimer les
abribus que d'essayer de les mettre
voilà cher Président je vous laisse le
mot de la fin si vous voulez
bien j'arrive un peu comme les
carabiniers pardonnez moi mais on ne
peut pas dire que depuis quelques jours
les questions
d'inflation normatives ne sont pas dans
le quotidien
médiatique politique et sociétal
et je
revois madame la réctrice en chef de
l'actualité juridique avec sa pile
devant elle qui me fait une injection de
rappel a-t-elle augmenté n'-t-elle pas
augmenté d'abord vous saluez madame la
présidente de la délégation collectivité
territoriale et la décentralisation ch
Françoise Gattel saluer le premier
vice-président Rémi pointer
particulièrement engagé sur ce sujet
saluer no collègues salue avec bonheur
mais on se revoit bientôt monsieur
carzavant la fin de ce mois le nouveau
président du Conseil national
d'évaluation des des normes et puis le
président adjoint de la section de
l'administration du Conseil d'État dont
j'ai compris que au travers de l'abribus
il vous aura révélé quelques réalités
qui ne nous met pas à l'abri d'un
certain nombre de recours de risque et
de
fragilité saluer le président de la
Conférence des inspecteurs et auditeurs
territoriaux Yanis vanli
et vous tous qui êtes ici je souhaiteris
d'abord vraiment vous remercier je
tenais à être là pardonnez-moi dearriver
que que maintenant la présidente
Françoise Gatel pour l'organisation de
cette matinée de sensibilisation au
conséquences de l'inflation normative
ainsi que Rémy po c'est un travail de
longue haleine mené par la délégation
qui vise simplifier les normes je
pense au rapport d'information sur la
simplification du droit de l'urbanisme
issu d'un groupe de travail présidé par
ru Po qui a débouché sur une proposition
de loi
transpartisane en 2016 voyez qu'on vient
de loi et adopté à l'unanimité au Sénat
elle n'a pas depuis été étudiée à
l'Assemblée
nationale mais serait pas inutile d'en
reprendre
l'esprit à second rapport qui visait à
réduire le poids des normes en aval de
leur production en 2019 et en
2023 le rapport que vous avez publié
madame la Présidente Monsieur premier
vice-président c'est normes applicable
aux collectivités territoriales face à
l'addiction
osant une thérapie de
choc un rapport avec nombreuses
propositions concrètes qui a débouché
c'était le 26 mars sur la signature avec
le gouvernement d'une charte
d'engagement visant à limiter le nombre
de normes et maintenant il faut qu'on
passe j'allais dire aux travaux
pratiques cette sensibilisation de ceux
qui fabriquent la loi fait partie des
actions prévu c'est une première pierre
et c'est très bien assis c'est vrai que
ce mal particulièrement français qui
consiste à adopter de plus en plus de
normes pensant répondre ainsi à tous les
problèmes étouff de plus en plus les
élus locaux qui réclament à corp et à
plus de liberté plus de pouvoir d'agir
c'était le thème du Congrès des Maes de
2022 les élu sont d'ailleurs pas
concernés seul écoutez les
agriculteurs pour moi-même est
exploitant je peux vous
dire sur les 6 codes 14
réglementations c'est pas une réalité
anecdotique pour plateau de télévision
c'est la vraie réalité
pour les élus je reprends vos chiffres
chè madame de Mac à l'occasion des états
généraux de la simplification on a bien
40 % de mots en plus dans le code de
l'urbanisme en une décennie un code
général des collectivité territoriale
qui lui a pris 300 % en 20 ans un code
de l'environnement multiplié par 10 sur
la même période je crois que on est en
train de tous mesurer que ça peut pas
durer ainsi en plus
je fais une digression euh qui est
actuellement le travail que que nous
conduisons dans la réflexion
institutionnelle au Sénat nous mettons
les élus en situation permanente euh de
fragilité de conflit et pardonnez-moi
je je pense toujours que depuis la loi
Fauchon de 2000 la situation
d'exposition des élus est aujourd'hui
très largement euh aggravée et donc nous
ferons des propositions au mois de mars
prochain sur ce sujet nous avons encore
hier matin la suite de travaux auquel
était associé Françoise Gatel avancé
dans ce débat sur la protection quelque
part juridique des élus non pas pour
affirmer qu'il serait au-dessus des lois
mais il y a un moment les situations
deviennent inextricables et je ne vous
parle pas des élus quand ils sont
euh à l'intérieur d'une société
d'économie mixte d'une SPL quand ils
sont eux-mêmes en situation dans de
toute petite collectivité d'avoir à
connaître de la vie associative et de la
décision du conseil municipal c'est
devenu aujourd'hui vraiment un état de
fragilité je le dis membbr éminent du
Conseil d'État c'est une véritable
préoccupation qui d'ailleurs aujourd'hui
désincite les élus à s'engager c'est un
point me semble-t-il extrêmement
important de nombreuses actions ont déjà
été menées pour limiter cette inflation
normative je pense notamment au travail
engagé par le Conseil national
d'évaluation des normes permettrait de
saluer alin Lambert dans le travail et
les relations que et le contact que nous
avons eu et et il a été aussi ici un
remarquable rapporteur général du budget
voyez comme quoi Monsieur carz c'est
contaminant d'une assemblée à l'autre
et je vous fais confiance cher Gill carz
on se connaitt bien pour qu'on avance
sur ce sujet de manière concrète
pragmatique il y a quand même un aspect
je me permets de le dire la chore de mon
papier on peut pas continuer à accepter
d'avoir une administration qui envoie
des demandes dans l'urgence pour
répondre le lendemain sans qu'on ait une
capacité d'évaluation déjà qu'on a des
études d'impact
indigente quand en plus on vous demande
de répondre en urgence comment voulezv
être en
capacité me
semble-t-il d'évaluer les conséquences
de ces n je pense que vous poursuivrez
naturellement avec engagement le travail
qui avait été engagé par Al
Lambert il faut limiter le nombre de
procédures d'urgence disposer d'études
d'impact solide tous les cas vraiment ça
fait parti des demandes du Sénat et nous
serons à vos côtés je souhaite cher Gill
car que nous ayons C relation
privilégié le Premier ministre dans son
discours de politique générale a rappelé
à plusieurs reprises le besoin de
débureaucratiser et de simplifier le
fonctionnement nos institutions
maintenant il faut passer aux actes
c'est comme ce que je disais en
conclusion au mois de mars dernier et
ben maintenant il faut passer aux actes
mais il faut qu'on ce dit je m'adresse à
mes collègues sénateurs il y a pas que
l'exécutif qui est responsable de la
multiplication des normes
nous sommes j'allais
dire j'allais dire ceux qui engendront
aussi c'est comme dans le livre de la
Genèse nous engendrons nous-mêmes un
certain nombre de normes et les
collectivités territoriales s'en
inventent en plus regardez les
règlements d'un certain nombre de
conseils régionaux de conseils
départementaux dans leur relation avec
les collectivités territorial je crois
donc que c'est une véritable révolution
collective auquel nous h appelé c'est
pourquoi que je pense que cette première
matinée éta importante il en faut
d'autres il faut que dans chacune des
commissions je sais que c'est cher à
votre cœur c'est un sujet un peu
complexe à à aborder mais on est une
vigie sur ce sujet dans chaque
commission et que surtout parfois pour
tenter d'avoir des convergences des
compromis a toutes les sensibilité
politique ici parfois on fabrique des
normes
supplémentaires et on le voit d'ailleurs
regardez l'inflation du nombre
d'articles dans tous nos
textes et je ne vous parle même pas des
propositions de loi nous partim 20 par
un PR renfort nous étions 90 pour
terminer j'ai en tête un texte 230
comment voulez-vous derrière tout ça
quelque part nous aurons contribué à
fabriquer cette complexité de norme je
crois qu'il y a une réflexion parce que
je crois que c'est un enjeu de vitalité
démocratique et il faut vraiment que les
uns et les autres en quelque sorte nous
contaminions nos collègues voilà ce que
je voulais vous dire d'abord pour vous
encourager dans ce travail parce que
vous pouvez avoir parfois le sentiment
de prêcher un peu dans le désert mais
euh ceux qu'on commença par prêcher dans
le désert ont plutôt réussi dans
l'histoire dans l'histoire longue de de
nos sociétés et donc je pense que vous
êtes dans cette situation en tous les
cas vous pouvez compter sur moi et merci
à tous ceux ont participé je me feraai
raconter l'histoire de l'abribus mais je
je crois pouvoir déjà le
deviner parce que entre l'arrê Debs d'un
collège qui dépend du conseil
départemental l'arrêt de
bus du lycée qui est intégré dans une
cité scolaire qui dépend du conseil
régional
l'arbus qui appartient au réseau de
transport de la communauté
d'agglomération il y a des débats
intérêt majeur dans lequel les
responsabilités sont largement partagées
pardonnez-moi c'est la vraie vie à
rambouiller parce que nous avons une
cité scolaire nous avons une communauté
d'aglot qui a hérité d'un réseau
municipal et que au moment d'implanter
l'abribus à certains moments et ben
finalement on ne l'implante pas et tout
le monde achète des parapluies ce qui
nous permet d'éviter mais c'est la vraie
vie que vivent les élus territoriaux les
élus locaux et c'est pour ça on va pas
raconter l'histoire mais je pourrais
vous raconter l'histoire de l'abribus du
lycée Louis Bascan à
rambouiller qui est d'ailleurs situé sur
une voie départementale en plus donc
vous avez tous les bonheurs tous les
bonheurs pour la réussite en tous les
cas merci d'avoir partagé cette matinée
ce matin ici dans l'hémicycle Médicis
voilà merci beaucoup cher président cela
confirme le fait que les sénateurs
n'ignorent rien de de la vraie vie leur
président encore moi donc vous pourrez
peut-être
rajouter un petit chapitre un petit
article cher Patrick girérard à cette
merveilleuse histoire de bus merci en
tout cas mes chers collègues d'avoir
participer à cette matinée merci à nos
intervenants c'est toujours un plaisir
euh de de d'échanger de travailler et le
président Larché Lali vous l'avez tous
dit c'est vraiment un travail collectif
chacun dans nos rôle et fonction devrait
devrait sur ce sur ce sujet et le
président a dit un mot sur la prise
illégale d'intérêt vous l'aviez dit euh
monsieur venling c'est un effectivement
un vrai sujet qui fait que même à un
moment à cause de du conflit d'intérêt
public public il n'y a plus de Corum
dans les dans les assemblées parce que
ceux qui ont été missionnés pour parler
de choses n'ont pas le droit d'en parler
c'est c'est un peu une autre histoire
que votre histoire de bus mais elle peut
être aussi drôlement racontée par vous
merci merci à tous et
donc je pense monsieur le Président moi
j'auris une dernière suggestion à faire
que l'efficience l'assiduité du sénateur
enfin du
parlementaire contient un critère qui
est celui le nombre le nombre
d'amendements déposés
et que le le top 10 ou le top 100 des
sénateurs varie largement selon le
nombre d'amendement déposés ou cigner et
je pense qu'il conviendrait aussi d'être
un peu pédagogue auprès de ces médias
pour qu'il comprennent que l'efficacité
n'est pas toujours dans la quantité mais
ailleurs c'était la suggestion du jour
cher président merci beaucoup chers
collègues le 8 février nous aurons le
plaisir d'accueillir Éric ver
dans le cadre de de de sa
mission qui doit contribuer à l'œuvre
collective d'efficacité de l'action
publique jusqu'au dernier kilomètre cher
Patrick merci merci à
tous